Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Gentlemen,
thank you very much for being here.
Really appreciate it.
Dr Khan,
uh,
before we get started,
why don't you tell everybody what your
background is.
Uh,
you will be representing the Vegan
portion of this discussion.
Tell people about yourself a little bit.
Thank you.
I feel like the head Broccoli in the
United States today,
but I am from motown,
motor city,
bad ass,
uh,
born and raised,
University of Michigan School of
Medicine,
summa cum laude,
internal medicine training,
cardiology training in Dallas,
Texas.
Very hard to be Vegan in Dallas,
but I did it in the eighties because
I've been doing this 42 year Vegan 42
years and that's impressive.
Age Eighteen and then a Kansas City,
Missouri and another tough town to eat
plants and only the steakhouse kc
masterpiece.
Did a training and stenting.
I was blasting open heart attacks from
1990 on,
came back to Michigan.
Very active cath lab,
heart attack.
You're dead.
I bring you back practice 24 hours a day
with great partners.
And about three to four years ago,
I used all these decades of plant based
medicine.
I've been basically bringing my family
up with and teaching patients,
but it opened a completely preventive
cardiology practice and along the way
with my wife and son,
we now own three plant based restaurants
too,
in Detroit.
One in Austin,
Texas,
right books.
Do TV,
write blogs,
teach,
and that can stop them.
One hundred 50 because there's a lot of
erectile dysfunction.
The stamp out.
That's my passion that.
Oh my God.
What else?
What better purpose in life?
Um,
well we can,
we can get to that.
Heart disease is somewhere in that mix
too.
And uh,
if people want to read more about you
website is.
Yeah,
Dr j o e l k a h n Dr Joel Kahn and
you've written a ton of books,
right?
A bunch of medical papers,
a whole lot of blogs.
Awesome.
And Chris?
Yeah,
Chris Kresser,
demand
or Grad at uc Berkeley and then got a
master's of science and I'm co director
of the California Center for Functional
Medicine,
which is a functional medicine clinic
and in here in California up in
Berkeley.
And,
uh,
I came to this from my own experience
with chronic illness.
I as,
as you know,
Joe got really sick,
uh,
back in my early twenties when I was
traveling around the world and uh,
you know,
conventional medicine didn't have much
to offer for me.
And so that led me on a path of trying
to figure out the best approach from a
diet and behavior and lifestyle
perspective to heal from my own chronic
illness.
And then that evolved into me starting
to write,
you know,
it started a blog and a website and
then,
um,
wrote a couple of books and now have a,
an organization that trains
practitioners in functional medicine and
also trains health.
And you add one point in time.
We're Vegan.
I was a macrobiotic Vegan.
I was apprenticing with a macrobiotic,
a chef.
So what's the difference?
Eating macrobiotic Vegan for folks and
irregular Vegan and macrobiotic is a
particular philosophy.
It's a particular approach that came
from Japan and um,
it's Vegan,
but it's,
it's,
you know,
it's heavily influenced by Japanese
tradition and cuisine and it has some
kind of different beliefs than us.
A typical vegan approach,
so I was uh,
when I was originally studying Chinese
medicine,
I was working in an apprenticing with a
macrobiotic Vegan chef and we were going
around cooking for people who are really
ill,
often people with cancer who were
following a macrobiotic diet.
And before that I had been a vegetarian
for quite a while as well.
What,
when I was traveling around the world
and got sick.
Actually I was,
I was vegetarian at that point too.
And you discovered through your own
personal.
We do it over there,
buddy.
You discovered over there through your
own personal practice that you,
your body worked better and your
illnesses went away when you changed
your diet away from macrobiotic?
Yeah.
For me personally,
I'm vegetarian diet and particularly
Vegan diet was a disaster,
but I'm just one person.
I don't put a lot of stock into a single
person's experience one way or the
other,
but certainly that did lead me down the
path of questioning some of my earlier
beliefs that I had about vegetarianism
and veganism and it led me to make some
different choices and that is important
to discuss here that everybody's body
really is different,
different people's bodies and
lifestyles.
They're going to have different
requirements.
Absolutely.
I mean,
I,
I would say,
just to start off this whole discussion,
if we're trying to answer the question,
what's the optimal diet for everyone?
I think that's a terrible question and
it's an unanswerable question,
uh,
where we share a lot in common as human
beings,
but we have a lot of important
differences to.
And from the beginning I've always
argued that there's no one size fits all
approach when it comes to diet.
Um,
but I think there are some common themes
and we can.
I'm sure we'll get to those later.
Yeah,
I think that's really important,
right?
It's really,
it's really important to discuss that
people really do have different
requirements.
Yeah.
And I mean,
we'll get into the mud a little bit as
we need to,
but we also,
Chris and I share a lot in common.
I mean,
one,
if we ate together,
it would probably be 90 percent the
same.
We both are really respectful of what we
call functional medicine,
root cause medicine.
I don't write scripts without thinking
about the patient.
He certainly doesn't do that without
thinking about the entire patient is
pretty unusual.
And we are going to represent a very
small section.
I,
I honor what he's doing with his new
book,
unconventional medicine.
The rest.
Yeah.
That is what is happening throughout
medicine.
Um,
and it's necessary because it just,
we're just running out of dollars in and
health when we're just pushing and not
even
asking the person what they eat,
how they sleep,
you know,
the whole thing,
we're real people.
Yeah.
We know that.
We don't agree on this,
but it's still rare jewel.
I mean this is to have,
you know,
this is pretty rare segment.
I don't know that two percent of the
people in America will have a patient
leaves the office and actually ask what
they
today,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean,
it doesn't happen.
Let me say one more thing about this
though,
because I think you hit on a really
important point and I'm glad you did.
Did it right off the bat.
The biggest problem with nutritional
research epidemiology is that it starts
with the assumption that there is one
diet for everybody.
That's,
that's something that's rarely
discussed,
but it's,
it's this idea that,
you know,
should everyone be on a low carb diet,
should everyone be on a high carb,
you know,
low fat or a low fat diet,
should everyone do this?
Should everyone do that?
And the whole,
um,
you know,
there's a guy in Australia,
professor who calls calls this approach
nutritionism this idea that we can
reduce foods down into these individual
components just like macronutrients,
protein,
fat,
carbohydrates,
and we can figure out what works best
for everyone just by looking at these
isolated components without considering
the,
the whole context of the Diet.
So I think,
you know,
Joel would agree that if you talk about
a diet that's 50 percent calories and
fat and one diet is they're getting all
of those fat calories from pizza and
chips and candy bars and things like
that,
and then another diet,
they're getting 50 percent of fat from
Avocados and olive oil and uh,
even,
you know,
eggs and animal foods,
those are two totally different diets.
And yet in the scientific literature,
those are equated as the same because
they're,
all they're looking at is the calories
from fat.
They're not considering the quality of
the Diet
and others add in,
and again,
we'd go anywhere with this conversation,
but a lot of the problem has been
imprecision of language.
So even the word low carb diet,
I had a low carb diet.
If we talk low refined carbs,
I don't eat white flour,
I don't eat sugar.
A very careful about all those
components.
I eat a very high complex carbohydrate
diet.
So we'll vegetables.
A giant study that's been released this
years appear study,
talks about carbs in the Diet.
They didn't differentiate complex and
refined very hard to know what to do
with data that doesn't spread that
apart.
And in your own life,
I mean low fat,
high fat.
I mean we need to talk about,
is it soybean oil that's processed and
rancid?
Are we talking about Avocados and uh,
you know,
healthy whole foods.
So the precision of language,
even protein protein.
The big divide is animal versus plant.
So anytime that word comes up we need to
differentiate what w know,
be precise and then will help more
people if we're precise.
Yeah.
And if you can just to eliminate this
for people.
What is the problem with epidemiology
studies?
Boy,
you know,
I'll,
I'll go there real quick.
I mean,
I don't think there's a problem,
but there are a part of the solution.
They're not the whole solution.
A lot scientists,
I'll give a shout out to Los Angeles,
brightest nutrition mine,
somebody that I know,
Chris Honors to Valter Longo,
no label and that Vegan that Pailin that
nothing.
He's at USC,
been honored by the Royal Academy of
Swedish medicine,
which is a Nobel prize committee in
this.
Now.
He says,
you know,
you do basic science and then you do an
epidemiology study to test the
hypothesis.
You've seen something in a petri dish,
you see something in a mouse,
you see something in a cell,
you asked the question,
is animal protein prolongevity pro early
aging,
explaining epidemiologists study people.
So you would take that concept.
I'll just run with that,
that you know,
you,
um,
you look at a,
uh,
an amino acid found in animal protein
thrown out.
Matthias and Lucy in a petri dish looks
like it might cause accelerated aging in
a single cell.
That's about chemistry.
That is something you honor,
but it's a long jump from there to a
human.
Then you look at a database.
Sometimes it's a crappy old database.
Sometimes it's Harvard has these
gigantic ongoing database.
A Loma Linda an hour from here has a
gigantic database and there's others
that epic study,
this pure study I mentioned,
you can test a hypothesis of what
happens if our data may be crappy,
but it's still data and it allows you to
go further with 100,000
people.
50,000
people,
500,000
people.
Can we,
do we have the data?
Ask the question,
does protein correlate with survival
protein correlate with early death,
animal protein,
plant protein?
These studies had been coming out a lot
lately and they let you parse it out.
Now it's what Chris talks about.
Do you know everything about the person
in the database?
Do you know smoke or do you know
diabetes or they go to the gym to lift
weights.
They smoke dope and smoke crack.
You know you don't know everything.
Nowadays.
Most of these things are going to ask,
are your blood pressure,
cholesterol,
all the basics to try and take those
factors away and isolate the question
you're asking.
It will be imperfect and then you go to
the best study,
but it won't.
It won't happen often.
The randomized clinical trial,
I mean,
there's never been a randomized clinical
trial smoking [inaudible] that'd be
unethical.
You're never going to do it.
It was epidemiology that proved and
association strong enough to recommend
to the public don't smoke.
They'll never be a randomized trial and
that everything,
parachutes don't need a randomized
trial,
you know,
um,
taking folic acid and a pregnant woman
to not have spinal Bifida doesn't need a
randomized trial.
I mean there's some things that are so
pressing.
The public health can't allow that and
there's even more than that.
The last little section is,
um,
you can study old people.
Chris enjoys studying ancient societies.
I enjoy studying the elderly in current,
you know,
modern environment,
which is called the blue zones and
there's others.
But you know,
what old people do,
the old healthy people.
Well,
we would like to be,
would you like to be 90 and have your
brains and have your joints and
everything working well,
we have that database so that little for
a pod,
a pedestal,
the sit on basic epidemiology,
randomized studies and centenarian
studies allows you to make reasonable
conclusions will be wrong.
Some things we're not going to be very
long,
Chris.
I think there's huge problems with
epidemiology.
So obser,
epidemiology,
observational studies are studies that
look at a certain group of people and
then try to draw inferences from their
behavior about associations with
disease.
So let's say we take a group and we look
and see,
you know,
how much saturated fat are they eating?
And we separate them into,
you know,
low consumption,
medium consumption,
high consumption,
and in a prospective study where we're
watching them over time,
we might then look 20 years later and
see how many people had heart attacks
and died.
Okay.
And then we try to correlate that with
their amount of saturated fat intake.
Now I actually just published two
articles with.
I'm going in detail on the problems with
observational nutritional research and
um,
you can find them at [inaudible] dot com
slash Rogan.
There's a whole bunch of information
that we're going to be talking about
today there so people can go and get the
details themselves.
But I'll just give you three of the,
I think the most,
the worst problems with nutritional
epidemiology.
The first is data collection.
So there's a saying in science,
which is that data are only as good as
the as the tool used to collect them.
All right?
And in nutritional observational
studies,
the tool used to collect data is a
questionnaire.
Okay?
And so that relies completely on memory
and we know that memory is not a
precise,
accurate or literal representation of
events.
It's more like a highly edited anecdote
of what happened in the past and back a
little bit like the cavenaugh thing.
Go now,
back in the bag in the 13th century you
had Francis Bacon.
He said,
for something to be scientific it has to
be independently observable,
measurable and falsifiable,
and then accurate and valid,
valid.
And so let's use an analogy.
If you're sitting there eating an apple
and I'm watching you do that,
I can observe that you're eating the
apple.
I can measure how much of the apple you
eat and I can confirm or refute that
you're eating the apple.
If you tell me that you were eating an
apple 15 years ago or 10 years ago,
I obviously can observe that.
I obviously can't measure it and I
obviously can't confirm or refute it and
yet our entire foundation of nutritional
epidemiology is based on that.
Basically people reporting on what they
ate at some time in the past,
so you know how much of a problem is
this.
A.
There's a guy named Edward Archer who's
done some really interesting studies and
he looked at the end Haynes data,
the nurses' health data,
which is one of the longest running
nutrition studies,
39 years,
and he found that the self reported
calorie intake in those studies was
either physiologically implausible or
incompatible with life,
so the average person in those studies
reported a calorie intake that would not
support an elderly bedridden frail
woman,
so they just.
It's just inaccurate.
It's completely inaccurate and the
people who are most likely to under
report or people who are overweight and
obese,
so if you if calories or that much under
reported,
all nutrition comes through calories.
Everything.
We get fat,
protein,
carbohydrates,
micronutrients.
They all come through calories,
so calories or that underreported,
that completely invalidates the Dataset.
This is an obesity study,
so the there are under reported because
of Shannon on an obesity study.
It's just every Americans are overweight
and obese.
The majority of Americans are overweight
and obese,
so in any data set of Americans are
going to have the majority of them
overweight or obese or are obese.
So that's the first problem.
The second problem is the healthy user
bias,
which I know we talked about before,
but it's basically the idea that because
you know when someone engages in an
unhealthy and a behavior that's
perceived as unhealthy,
they are more likely to engage in other
behaviors that are perceived as
unhealthy and vice versa.
So let's say you do a study of people
who ate eat more red meat.
Red Meat has been perceived as unhealthy
for a long time,
and so what we know is that in those
observational studies,
that people who eat more red meat are
also smoking more.
They have higher body mass index.
They're eating less,
fewer fruits and vegetables.
They have a lower level of education.
They're less physically active.
So how do you know that it's the red
meat that's causing the problem and not
those other things you don't because
they cannot control for all of those
potential confounding factors.
The third problem with observational
research,
and maybe the biggest is that the the
relative risks in nutrition are so low
that they're indistinguishable from
chance.
So in fields outside of nutrition and
epidemiology,
nobody would consider a relative risk an
increase in risk less than 100 percent.
A doubling to be really worth paying
attention to.
So to put this in perspective,
the observational studies that Joel was
referring to that confirmed that is that
cigarette smoking led to lung cancer
that showed in between a 1000 and 3000
percent increase in lung cancer in
smokers.
Okay.
And the studies that have shown that
eating aflatoxin,
which is a mycotoxin increased liver
cancer risk,
that's 600 percent increase.
Okay.
The AIA,
the I a arc,
the WHO report that suggested that
process,
red meat was a carcinogen.
That was 18 percent increase.
Most epidemiologists you've talked to
will say that is so low that it's really
interesting.
Indistinguishable from chance,
especially given the healthy user bias
and the problems with the data
collection that I mentioned before.
So the studies that are cited,
so when people are talking about red
meat causes cancer,
they're literally talking about
something that showed an 18 percent
increase.
Yeah.
And this is over a depot that are also
consuming sugar.
That translates into four and a half.
There were four and a half cases of
cancer out of 100 and people with no
lowest intake of processed meat.
And that went up to five point three
cases out of 100 and people with the
highest intake of processed meat.
So,
you know,
there are quotes like if you,
if you look even 20 years ago,
like there's an article in science,
um,
the journal Science and Marsha Anjell
who was the former editor of New England
Journal of Medicine,
was quoted as saying we wouldn't even
accept a paper for publication if it
didn't have at least a 200 percent
increase,
especially if it was a new association
or the,
the,
the biological mechanism wasn't known.
And here we are today saying that you
know,
this increase that by seven percent or
by 10 percent and when you consider that
the data is usually questionnaires of
what people ate and all of these
confounding factors like exercise and
and fruit and vegetable consumption and
things like that are not accounted for.
Then we're really just playing games
with numbers as part of the problem as
well,
that there's this clickbait culture now
in terms of journalism where they just
want to publish something that says
eight study shows,
18 percent of people eat red meat,
get cancer.
That's a huge problem.
And there is a study that was done that
showed that 43 percent of findings came
from observational studies were
portrayed in the media as being causal,
which,
which any epidemiologists would tell you
that that's a full pot.
You can't do that,
but nobody is going to click on a
headline that says,
you know,
small association between these two
variables scene,
we don't know what it means,
but please read the stories.
Interesting.
Let me just grab a couple and again,
a lot of respect and agreement.
But if we throw a bid deem ecology away,
we thrown away about 80 percent of
nutrition knowledge because that is the
most common kind of study and that still
leaves us with basic science,
which is rockin.
It leaves us with a randomized clinical
trials which are very hard nutrition and
they're very expensive and there's less
than we need.
And if finally leaves us with the
studying old healthy people centenarian
studies,
but does go to Loma Linda 10 times more
people in Loma Linda are over 100 than
there are in Los Angeles 10 times more.
That's by definition.
Yeah,
it's called the blue zone.
And we'll talk about blue zone.
But that was discovered in the 19
fifties.
If you lived in Loma Linda,
you were living 12.
Some of those an hour east of here.
It's what's going on with the center of
the seventh day adventist church,
which teaches people eat your veggies,
don't drink,
don't smoke and exercise.
So it's an amazing lifestyle oriented,
uh,
aspect of the Christian church.
And they in 1958 got huge funding from
the government to explore.
Why the heck are they live in 12 years,
eight years,
10 years longer,
and they've parsed that out and probably
a thousand publications there.
It's not a randomized study,
you know,
it was an la versus Loma Linda will feed
you different diets and fought.
Won't ever happen,
but it is a reliable longterm peer
review.
This stuff's published,
the finest of journals and it at least
lets you ask questions.
I mean why is there a 104 year old
cardiac surgeon,
Elliot wore sham walking around doing
his gardening and he just finished
operating on a heart patients.
I mean,
it's insane for a award.
Show him love you buddy.
So let me go back for a minute.
If we throw epidemiology out,
we are left with basically.
No,
I know,
but so food.
This is all technical stuff and but
you've got a sophisticated audience.
Food frequency questionnaires with Chris
said is the source of a lot of these
epidemiologists states you fill out a
four page,
a 40 page at in Loma Linda to 58 page
survey,
but you do it once.
That's called the pure study.
The headlines.
You've seen them,
cheese,
eggs,
meat,
or good for your heart.
It's been the news the last two weeks
that comes from a giant international
study.
They did one food frequency
questionnaire at the beginning.
Twelve years later,
the reporting that data,
it's all click bait headlines.
It's like you say,
people love to see this stuff,
so if we throw out some studies,
we have to throw out the largest
nutritional study that's been reported
and the most recent one that's getting
all the headlines.
It's got to be played fair.
Now you go to Loma Linda.
It's every four years.
They're asking you go to Harvard school
public health every four years they
update the data,
so if you change your diet,
that's the weakness.
You fill out the survey and then you get
healthy or you get sick and you make
changes and then they're counting of
your debt or lie.
Well,
it might be what you did.
Your six now what you filled out year
one,
so there are.
There are better and worse forms.
The second I'd say healthy user bias is
the idea that people pick a certain diet
might have other lifestyles.
It might be as or more important.
It's going to be true of the Paleo
Group.
I mean,
these guys are gonna.
Look at Chris.
He looks wonderful.
He Se thin.
He's not the obese American,
the 75 percent that are overweight and
obese.
I mean that's true in the plant
community to some extent.
We have Chubby vegans like there's no
observational studies with significant
number of Paleo dieters too.
I know.
I know that a healthy user bias is not
an issue for Leo,
but if you don't have data doesn't mean.
I mean you don't have data because it's
a new movement that hasn't had the data,
but it's not the cast stones that plant
based Cedars go to the gym more.
It's probably true.
We don't know,
but.
And that's a third thing to stop you for
a second.
Yeah.
Mediators do get lumped in with the
Paleo group.
They consider Paleo group part of the
meat eater group.
Like when people talk about these
epidemiologic.
Yeah.
Epidemiology studies where they show
that people that consume red meat more
likely to get sick on my leg to cancer.
They're not referring to Paleo diet or
consider eating avocado and grass fed.
You gotta.
Remember,
most of the Paleo movement is the last
dozen,
15 years,
you know,
we can talk about that in 1985,
2000 to Loren cordain publishers book in
2002.
The book didn't sell,
republished 2010.
It took off.
This is a relatively new moment,
so if you filled out the study and Loma
Linda in 1958,
you don't have to worry.
There weren't too many people following
a classic Paleo Diet.
This also true at Harvard,
these initiatives,
the last is just a relative risk.
That's what we call it.
These are pure statistics.
I'm a,
I'm a heart attack,
not a statistician,
but there are some exceptions.
I mean anybody,
and I'll just say I've got a red button
on my website that says Rogan references
because I thought it would be good to
have people a place to go,
just like Chris mentioned,
and I'm not massaging the data.
It's scientific peer reviewed data.
Um,
there was a study in October,
2016,
October one,
2016 songs from Harvard,
6,000
people observational data,
animal protein,
plant protein.
They actually let me go to 2014.
Morgan Levine,
this is an amazing Harvard researcher,
beautiful woman,
Morgan Levine.
She looked at 6,000
people prospectively,
observation,
fill out all these data.
If you were an animal protein eater
that's called meat,
you had a three to 400 percent increase
in cancer risk.
Three to 400 percent.
That's three to four times isn't one
point one,
one point.
Oh,
eight,
18 percent.
The data's there.
This is peer reviewed data.
If you ate plant based proteins,
risk of cancer goes down.
This is in the highest pause for a
second.
I just want to say there are nutritional
data that are powerful,
but this is also an epidemiology study.
That's where 18 in a,
nobody's going to do a randomized study
of 6,000
people.
You eat beans,
you eat
this.
And I think I have a,
a good example that can clear some of
this.
Uh,
so,
um,
you mentioned the Loma Linda and the
seventh day adventist studies.
So,
um,
first of all,
let me just make a comment about
observational nutritional research.
It can,
there are good observational studies in
there,
bad ones you can design an observational
study in a way that controls for some of
these potentially confounding factors
like the healthy user bias,
et cetera.
So,
but this is a story that will,
I think clear some of this up.
So there are about eight studies,
major studies that have compared
lifespan and in a vegetarians and vegans
and omnivores.
So the earlier studies are three studies
that were seventh day adventist studies,
so they were done in the seventh day
adventist community,
which Joel mentioned.
Is it religious group that has as part
of its credo,
you know,
a healthy lifestyle diet and lifestyle.
Um,
yeah,
by 20,
20 million people,
let's not talk over each other.
Let's just make sure we catch a
vegetarian vegetarian diet,
but also,
you know,
eat a live healthy fruits and
vegetables,
don't smoke,
don't drink excessively,
etc.
So you know,
health conscious group of people and the
the,
the first one on the seventh day
adventist study in the Netherlands,
compared them with the general
population,
which is just garbage because of the
healthy user bias so we can just cross
that one off the list.
The two Seventh day adventist studies
that were done in loma linda and the us,
they did a better job because they
compared people who do eat meat amongst
the seventh day adventist population
with people who don't and was a slight
advantage in lifespan and in the
vegetarians versus the mediators.
But one of those studies didn't control
for smoking and body mass index.
So that data is highly suspect.
And the other study did and there was a
slight advantage since then.
There have been four studies that I
think did a much better job.
So this is kind of an interesting
design.
So they said let's try to find a group
of more health conscious omnivores to
compare these vegetarians against.
So they.
The first one was called the health food
shopper study.
So they looked at people who shopped at
health food stores.
When the idea is people who shopped at
health food stores are going to be
generally more health conscious and they
found health food store,
you mean like a whole foods or I.
There was no whole foods at this point,
but that was the idea.
Right.
And so that study found that both
groups,
vegetarians and omnivores who shopped at
health food stores had us hugely reduced
risk of death compared to the general
population,
but there was no difference between
vegetarians and omnivores.
Second study,
oxford vegetarian study in the uk,
they recruited people buy first they
recruited vegetarians and then they
asked the vegetarians to ask their
friends who also ate meat so that the
idea was the people that are vegetarians
were hanging out with,
might be more health conscious than the
general population.
Same result,
big difference in the,
in,
in life span between those two groups in
the general population,
but no difference between vegetarians
and omnivores.
Epic oxford cohort.
Same thing,
same way of recruiting people.
Same result,
big difference,
uh,
between the two groups in the omnivores,
but no difference between vegetarians
and omnivores.
And then the heidelberg study was in the
in Germany and in a similar way,
I think they recruited people who read
vegetarian magazines and then they asked
them to bring their friends or family
members who ate meat.
Big difference in lifespan between the
two groups and general population,
no difference between vegetarians and
omnivores.
And then you had the 45 and up study
that was recently done in Australia.
This was a little different because they
didn't set out to find,
you know,
more health conscious people.
Instead they looked at 250,000
people,
big sample size and they did a much
better job of controlling for all of the
various factors that might affect the
results.
So exercise,
physical activity,
fruit and vegetable consumption,
cigarette smoking,
alcohol education level because we know
that has a big impact on lifespan and
they found that there was no difference
in lifespan between omnivores and
vegetarians in that study as well.
And then there've been two meta analysis
of all of the studies that have looked
at this.
Both meta analysis found no difference
between vegetarians and omnivores in
total in lifespan.
So I think this is a really good example
of what we're talkiNg about here.
that's all observational data,
so we're not throwing it out or saying
we should throw it out,
but all of those studies did a better
job at dealing with the potential
pitfalls of observational studies.
And when they did that they found no
difference.
So,
and I want to point out that it,
those ways of picking more health
conscious omnivores were they still
weren't comparing like someone on a
paleo type of diet with a vegetarian.
They were just guessing that someone who
shopped at a health food store was at
least a little more conscious about
health in the general population.
So quick little cleanup.
Quick,
quick,
quick.
Luckily I just want to go back for a
minute to meet in cancer.
World health organization is not a vegan
group.
It's not enough in group now.
It's a fairly well respected
international organization that puts out
health claims.
So although I absolutely chris had the
data right,
18 percent increase in cancer risk with
process red meat.
I want to make that clear.
I hope you don't eat too many hot dogs.
Lie me,
bologna,
pepperoni.
That's the uh,
well,
it may be more than nature,
but it's just a hallway.
It's assault.
That's a preservatives.
It's junky pieces of the animal that
they're putting into a hot dog.
That was a group that's an 18 percent
increase.
You can go forward and a half percent of
five and a half percent.
That's still 50 to 60,000
people a year.
They get colon cancer.
If that data's right,
they wouldn't get colon cancer if they
just would stop eating hot hotdogs at a
minimum.
And I know chris will agree.
Frigging hospitals are serving hot dogs
and the data's out there that it
promotes cancer to people getting
chemotherapy with the ivy pool.
It's insanity.
So 50,000
people avoid colorectal cancer with
small differences that the world health
organization suggests it was 800 papers
in 22 world experts.
There is no perfect study,
but when they announced it,
October 25th,
2015,
the world was shocked.
You just said that process red meat
causes cancer.
They didn't say related.
They were strong enough data to say
cause they've been beat up.
They publish more data.
They haven't backed down,
I just want to put that out.
The healthy user bias will exist in the
paleo community when the study's done
because they may look at paleo effects
there.
It's everything and I honored that.
I mean we should promote healthy
lifestyle foods.
Only one part of this.
I mean we will all at this table live
longer than the average american.
We're not smoking two packs a day.
We don't have 38 inch waist lines.
The whole deal.
We're doing the whole thing.
Hopefully you guys are enjoying a little
cabernet now and then or a that's always
on the list.
Just don't overdo it,
but the healthy user bias,
that particular that health food study
paper with 1996,
it's pretty old paper in the paper in
the limitations.
They beat themselves up.
we were missing this or that.
Anybody just read the paper.
It's not that it doesn't bring up an
interesting point,
but to say that we again throw away all
these papers cause they are biased it.
Lastly,
and I'm done multivariate analysis.
Chris was just talking about better
studies that factor all this stuff.
Let's not bore your audience was
statistics statistics,
but there's certainly the ability now to
say,
does animal protein associated with an
increased risk of cancer and put in
smoking and weight and diabetes and
blood pressure and vegetable intake and
alcohol intake and family history,
and then you just isolate the one thing
is their foibles.
Are There downsides?
Of course,
but all modern epidemiology does
multivariate analysis to try and isolate
it.
You know,
you can cast stones everywhere,
but you know there are the,
you know,
the world health organization mean
there's 21.
Organizations
say limit your saturated fat in your
diet and none that are international
society say increase at soap,
you put it.
Nutrition science needs incorporate as
much as you can with as much reliability
and at the end of the day you can see
we'll still have questions,
but I can't threaten us.
Used to say don't eat much cholesterol.
Now they don't.
They used to say limit your total fat
and now they don't.
It's wrong because they've gone out is
wrong.
actually,
the usta says in the guideline,
eat as little cholesterol is not a
nutrient of concern because they
couldn't identify the exact milligrams
to recommend.
Used to be 300.
The science doesn't support it's
emitting dietary cholesterol anymore.
Let me go back to the the limit
cholesterol.
Limit cholesterol to as little as
possible.
I mean,
what's this thing?
Who is the usda?
Usda,
usda.
The guidelines come out every five years
and they are in used for school menus
and hospital menus.
it was a big buzz in 2016 was announced.
They no Longer were giving a so many
miLligrams of cholesterol day.
You'd never exceed.
They said,
we can't pick the number.
Usd a behind the cUrve in termS of a
little bit influential.
Total mortality is the most important
end point we should be talking about
here.
That means deaths from any cause.
Okay,
so if,
because that's what we care about most,
right?
If,
if I die of a,
you know,
if,
if I,
if an intervention reduces the risk of a
heart attack but increases the risk of
cancer,
I'm not happy with that.
In fact,
I'd rather go out,
have a heart attack,
and so you need to consider a total
mortality and if something,
you know,
if meat increases the risk of cancer and
cancer mortality,
then why aren't we seeing that in the
studies that compared lifespan with
vegetarians and omnivores?
We have,
as I said,
we have a five studies that did a better
job of controlling for that healthy user
bias and there was no difference in any
of those studies.
There is not a single study that showed
that compared relatively equivalent
groups of people that shows that
vegetarians or vegans have a lifespan
advantage period.
There is not.
And so if you know red meat isn't.
If we're saying red meat,
processed meat increases the risk of
cancer by 18 percent,
maybe,
maybe not,
but that's not showing up in any of the
total.
The total mortality data.
The second thing,
and this is a really good example of
what we talked about,
the very beginning of the show context
is everything.
Quality is more important than quantity.
So let's talk.
Let's think about processed meat.
So there's several proposed mechanisms
for how processed meat causes cancer.
One is that it increases and nitros,
so compounds or [inaudible],
which damage damage,
the gut lining,
and others that,
uh,
they,
when you cook meat at a high
temperatures,
at forums,
heterocyclic,
any means or hcas which damaged the gut.
Another is that the heme iron content in
meat causes oxidative stress and
increases the risk of cancer that way.
And then there's and new five gc.
But let me just give you a few examples
of why context is important.
So there's evidence that chlorophyll
rich green vegetables prevent myoglobin
from being turned into end nitros.
So compound.
So if you're eating processed meat but
you're also eating kale and broccoli,
then it's not going to have the same
effect on the body as if you're just
eating a hot dog.
I'm cruciferous vegetables and spices
and marinades have been shown to reduce
the formation of heterocyclic amines or
hta.
So same thing if you're,
if you're marinating meat or if you're
eating broccoli and cruciferous
vegetables with meat,
it's not going to have the same impact.
There are several studies have shown
that eating fruits and vegetables
attenuates the oxidative capacity of
heme iron and even reduces the
absorption of heme iron in the gut.
And,
uh,
you know,
dietary antioxidants have been shown to
reduce the risk of gastric cancer.
So heme iron intake,
really you can think of it as a proxy
for a crappy diet.
In these observational studies,
there was a quote from a study that did
find a relationship with heme iron and
cardiovascular disease and the but the
study,
the study author himself said,
with respect to heme iron intake,
we found a significant association only
in the studies that were based on
american cohorts.
They didn't find an association than the
Netherlands,
Canada,
France,
Italy,
Japan,
and Sweden,
which suggests that it's because of the
standard crappy american diet.
You know,
most people are eating processed meat
in,
in the us are eating it in the form of
hot dogs and all kinds of other
unhealthy foods.
Sugar.
And it's another example of how that
user.
But I'm not saying I'm open to the
possibility that too much processed meat
can be problematic,
but you have to consider the context.
It's not going to have the same effect
if someone's eating a ton of fruits and
vegetables versus someone who's on a
standard american diet and we have no
studies that separate that out.
Okay.
I think we have a gong moment because I
really want your listeners to come away
with a few tips from chris and I that
make a difference because I know your
listeners aren't going to stop eating
meat at the end of the show.
They might.
Chris just said meat with vegetables is
safer.
The meat without vegetables.
Meat with chlorophyll is safe for the
meat without.
I can give you a cardiac study.
Said,
agree.
I.
I teach process me.
Well,
it's all made.
I teach the same.
No.
Listen,
we agree here.
I want people to hear this,
but doing.
When you grill,
how many people in the audience grill
barbecue?
Everybody.
If you grill meat,
another chemical group that's formed are
called advanced glycation end products.
Age to go along with the list,
but if you grill meat that's marinated
and this was the tip in dark beer,
this is science randomized science.
You put a piece of beef in dark beer and
your grill it.
You don't create as many of these toxic
chemicals as a dry piece of beef.
So let's.
Let's like right now everybody
listening,
next time you eat meat,
get a salad.
Next time we meet order broccoli.
Next time you have get a
get a,
you know,
slice tomatoes,
you will actually improve your health.
There's this classic announced shift
into cardiology that they took a healthy
volunteers and they took them down to
the hospital cafeteria and they fed them
a hospital burger and they were
measuring on their arm how there are
arteries function,
cardiology topic,
artery function goes down in three
hours.
We needed a hospital Burger.
It x like you just had a toxin in your
body.
You did.
They took the same group.
A week later they had them meet the same
burger with a big salad.
They didn't see that finding.
I mean,
I want this to be an important point and
every body should be jamming fruits and
vegetables or at least the vegetables
with some fruits.
You can go low glycaemic berries.
I'm fine with papayas,
cantaloupe,
and apples,
but you know up your veggies listeners
and you'll counteract lot of the crap
that's out there in the world and it's
an important message.
I don't disagree with that.
No,
you wouldn't.
You have to.
We'd glossed over this very quickly in
the beginning of this,
but there was a dispute about
cholesterol and a dispute about
saturated fat.
Ah,
sears.
You were saying that saturated fat,
that there's recommendations to reduce
saturated fat and reduced cholesterol.
So let,
let me go real quick overview and I'm
going to talk fast.
So just normal.
Yeah,
it was plenty of time.
It was felt so until the forties.
It was not common to have a heart
attack.
Heart attacks were described in 1916.
Not to say that didn't happen,
but the first medical article that used
the word myocardial infarction 19,
16,
1940.
There were not many heart attacks seen
in a modern american city.
After world war two,
we are economy went up in the city of
minneapolis.
Executives started suffering heart
attacks.
It was also franklin delano roosevelt
died of high blood pressure.
A few years later,
eisenhower had a massive heart attack.
That's when our government,
national institutes of health started
funneling major money into studies like
the framingham study or from newton
framingham's,
the city outside of boston,
and they basically invaded this town in
1958.
Today is that we're spending money.
We're going to figure this crap out.
The idea had come up.
Heart disease wasn't just aging.
Heart disease could be explained by
what's called risk factors.
Smoking might not.
You can smoke and live to a hundred,
but it's going to increase your risk and
then the gun to blood pressure and
cholesterol and a family history.
They identified what we call risk
factors,
so until that point,
diet was not considered a factor in the
development.
The number one killer of men and women I
want to point out,
and chris puts this on his website.
I do too.
During this interview,
every 39 seconds and american dies of
heart disease every 39 second most
frequent cause of death,
so there will be about 200 people
perhaps that will die during this
podcast.
The number one killer and 80 percent of
it's preventable.
Chris is going to prevent some.
I'm going to prevent some because the
biggest enemy out there smoking and
crap,
diet,
calorie rich and processed foods,
crap,
sad diet,
standard american diet.
It becAme apparent in the early 19
fifties diet might play a role and a
notorious scientists and many others.
His name dr.
Ancil keys,
phd,
phd at two of them suggested dietary fat
might be a factor.
It was a hypothesis.
It says early stage epidemiology doesn't
prove anything.
He went out and did studies.
Other people went out and did studies
and the idea of transitioned actually he
was criticized for saying dietary fat.
That is the conversation transition.
There's some good fats like omega three
fatty acids are essential.
You have to have them,
and then maybe polyunsaturated fats from
plants are more helpful,
but the focus went on saturated fat in
food,
which is bacon,
chicken,
red meat,
pizza.
Those are the highest sources.
And,
um,
subsequently enough data accumulated.
That guideline started to suggest we've
got this huge problem with heart
disease.
We should limit saturated fat in the
diet.
It was never limit off that 35 percent
of calories that's not in anybody's
word,
a low fat diet.
Um,
and that has now promulgated in 21
international statements,
there is no opposite whether it's a
world health organization,
the american heart association,
american college of cardiology,
whether it's an institute of institute
of medicine,
says eat as little saturated fat as
possible.
They couldn't be more clear.
And these are high brow.
These are not associated with vegan
movements or paleo movements or
whatever.
These are medical authorities.
If there was half and half,
you'd say controversy,
21 to 21 say the same thing,
they might pick a different cutoff
point,
but we will enhance the health and cut
down the number one killer,
whether it's in asia,
whether the job,
whether it's Australia,
whether it's a in the United States,
there's unanimity in why did they come
to the basic science?
Because there is basic science and let
me tell you that when you eat foods rich
and saturated fat,
which is called meat,
cheese,
eggs,
and such receptors on your liver for
cholesterol,
I've got cholesterol,
my blood,
I'd like to get some of it out into the
liver to be metabolized.
I need a receptor.
You eat saturated fats.
Receptors go down.
Cholesterol has no place to go.
Cholesterol stays In the blood,
bumps into your artery wall.
I'm putting a stent in yardi.
That's the basic biochemistry.
Then they had epidemiology studies,
flawed.
Perfect.
It doesn't matter.
There was.
Whoa,
chris,
thank you very much.
Then they did controlled trials.
Three.
Everybody just go read clark.
Nineteen 97 slash 395.
It's called metabolic studies,
changed the diet.
See what happens.
You add saturated fat,
cholesterol skyrockets on average,
not in a single person.
If I give you a state christmas taken
mistake,
our cluster would rise differently.
It would rise.
It would rise differently.
It's our microbiome,
it's our genetics.
It would rise,
so it.
That's a problem in the studies when you
average everything together.
So they had that and then finally,
finally they looked at populations that
live over 100.
These are called the pillars of
longevity.
They don't eat foods rich in saturated
fat.
They have a little,
they don't have a lot.
They eat a lot of olive oil in Italy and
Greece.
They eat almost no dietary fat in
okinawa,
Japan and they live.
They have the greatest longevity in the
world.
In 1970,
they almost no dietary fat.
About six,
seven percent.
Okay.
All right.
Well no,
it'S actually.
That is the basis for a major push to
say cut back on animal products
because that's largely with the
exception of coconut and palm.
We're saturated fat comes from so that
to tiffany gate,
that is to throw out every major health
agency in the world.
And I don't believe chris kresser can do
that.
No disrespect.
I don't think chris can throw out a
hundred years of cluster.
Let's back up a little bit here.
Yeah.
So,
um,
first of all,
every food that we consume has all of
the fats in it,
polyunsaturated,
monounsaturated and saturated fat.
And in fact,
two tablespoons of olive oil has more
saturated fat than a seven ounce pork
chop.
That's a little known fact.
The oily fish macro,
which all of these health agencies that
joel was talking about advises us to
eat,
has twice the total fat in one and a
half times the saturated fat that we're
of the meat that we're told to avoid.
Um,
does it make sense that nature would
include the,
that you could eat a macro and the
polyunsaturated fats in it are good for
you,
but the saturated fat in it is bad for
you.
That'S kind of nonsensical.
But you know,
let's talk a little bit more about the
research.
So there never really was good evidence
to suggest that dietary cholesterol and
saturated fat are connected to heart
disease.
And zoe heart comb,
who's a,
has a phd in nutritional researcher,
she wrote her thesis,
her phd thesis on the evidence back in
the seventies that led to the
restrictions on a saturated fat and
cholesterol.
And then she also reviewed the evidence.
You're all the way up until the 2016.
And,
and if,
uh,
I have this information on my website,
if you go to [inaudible] dot com slash
rogan,
you can find it and what you'll find is
there never was in really good evidence
to support the limitations on die on
saturated fat and cholesterol.
And people have started to look at this
more recently.
And uh,
for example,
you have a meta analysis of
observational studies including about
350,000
participants recently that found no
relationship between saturated fat
intake and cardiovascular disease.
You have an exhaustive review of
studies,
something like 25 randomized controlled
trials,
gold standard of clinical evidence.
And it's almost 40 observational studies
involving 650,000
participants.
And I'll read you a quote from the
conclusion,
current evidence does not clearly
support cardiovascular guidelines that
encourage high consumption of
polyunsaturated fatty acids and low
consumption of saturated fatty acids.
Now,
look,
one of my favorite quotes is the
philosopher anatoly France,
even a $50 million people say a foolish
thing.
It's still a foolish thing.
And the other thing to consider is that
the history of science is really the
history of most scientists being wrong
about most things most of the time.
and,
uh,
you know,
in science we have to continually
challenge our hypotheses and try to
falsify them.
And that'S how the scientific process
moves forward.
And that's why in 2010,
theu ,
s federal government removed
restrictions on total fat.
Whereas before There was a restriction
on total fat because they,
they acknowledged that the research was
showing that not all fat is the same and
that,
you know,
we don't need to be restricting fat from
avocados and things like that.
And in 2015,
they removed the restriction on dietary
cholesterol.
Now they did that fairly quietly because
how do you think it looks when people
have been told to limit their fat and
limit their cholesterol and then the
federal agency goes back on that,
that recommendation after so many years
of telling people to do that,
people lose faith in the agencies that
are,
that are issuing these guidelines and
don't take it for me.
you know,
I'm,
I'm not expecting anyone to believe me,
and that's why I put all of the studies
and the research supporting this at
[inaudible] dot com slash rogan,
but how about johnny enedis,
who's one of the most renowned
epidemiologists in the world?
He's a professor of medicine at stanford
and he has wrote some written,
some scathing critiques of nutritional
research recently that had been
published in jama and british medical
journal.
So here's a quote from one of them,
some nutrition scientist and much of the
public often consider epidemiological
associations of nutritional factors to
represent causal effects that can inform
public health policy and guidelines.
However,
the emerging picture of nutritional
epidemiology is difficult to reconcile
with good scientific principles.
The field needs radical reform and he
goes on to point out that med analyses
of observational studies have found that
almost all foods are associated with a
higher risk of death if you crunch the
data in certain ways.
So,
uh,
it's not enough to say that,
you know,
governments are recommending this or
that we have to look at the science and
what the science is saying.
And as I said,
you two recent med analysis covering
over a million people are not showing a
relationship between saturated fat and
heart disease and they're not showing
any benefit from replacing saturated fat
with polyunsaturated fats.
So these organizations,
joel,
you were describing,
why do you think that they recommend,
based on what chris has just said,
why do you think that they recommend
reducing your saturated fat?
Reducing your cholesterol?
Okay.
Um,
and thank you and you know,
the important here,
which we are technical in the weeds,
but I want to bring it back.
This discussion is,
do you have a stroke,
heart attack,
erectile dysfunction,
lose a leg,
or do you not?
Because at least one factor in
development of these horrible medical
problems that are 80 percent
preventable,
at least one of it is nutrition and the
continuity.
Nutrition.
I mean,
there's no doubt it's the single most
important factor.
It's never been the only fact that
organizations are saying this.
He's saying social studies don't support
that.
Well,
uh,
I disagree.
The science and
I want to be very specific.
Let's talk about cholesterol.
Let's talk about saturated fat.
So stay with saturated fat because there
is differences there.
They're both,
uh,
you know,
contents of food,
fatty contents of food,
but they're chemically different in the
volume.
Weight is very,
very different.
Cholesterol only comes from animal
saturated fat as animals and plants
depending on the food source.
So when this rise in heart attacks
developed,
research began 19,
48 and 1950,
1958.
There were observations made that
carefully done dietary logs,
suggested these were hypotheses.
There might be a connection between what
you eat and heart attacks.
And then it's centered on,
um,
you know,
is it foods high in protein,
foods,
high sugar,
high in fatty sources.
Ultimately they get sophisticated foods
high in plant fat sources,
foods high in animal fat sources,
so by the late 19 fifties there was a
very strong consensus already that foods
high in animal products with saturated
fat.
They go together.
We're talking to meat,
egg and cheese may be a role.
Why?
Let me give you a great example.
in 1959,
you grew up in Japan.
You have a cholesterol of 120.
You almost never see a heart attack.
You moved to Hawaii because there's
migration.
Your cholesterol rises to a hundred 80.
Welcome to America.
Your heart attack,
risk triples.
You move to this great city,
los angeles,
this was published in 1959.
Your cholesterol is now 2:10.
You have 10 times the heart attack risk
that you had when you lived in Japan.
Genetics don't change that quick.
This was within one generation.
They're called nisei.
People that leave Japan to move to
California,
the nisei,
and there's the knee say,
hon,
study that.
Track these people.
now,
is that the air?
Is it that they adopted other bad
habits?
Shirt could be,
but within a very short time that 10
times the risk of heart attack,
so public research and dollars,
this stuff is correlated with animal
fats and proteins.
Why isn't correlated with sugar and
refined carbohydrates so carefully done
studies say,
and I think we all agree more so now
because we're overweight and now we're
more insulin resistant and added sugars
in the diet are more important in 2018
than they were when in the country was
thin in 1960.
They weren't good then.
They aren't good now,
but when you parse it out,
multivariate analysis,
there's a stronger relationship between
the number one.
food in studies like this is usually
butter more than red meat.
It's actually butter.
That's just at our value.
It's called statistic.
I don't want to go so deep into
statistics.
It is somewhere there is sugar.
I'll give you a classic study.
If you could hold sugar the same and
increased dietary saturated fat,
heart disease,
rockets.
If you could hold saturated fat,
the same.
Increased sugar in these manipulations.
Coronary heart disease doesn't increase.
Let's point something out.
I've been inside of hearts 15,000
times.
I've never scooped sugar out of a
blocked artery as scooped cholesterol
out of blocked arteries.
Twenty percent of every blockage in a
heart is cholesterol.
So fact that was discovered in 1910.
It's never varied.
Then we fed animal.
Let's pause for a second,
chris,
you have something to say about that?
Yeah,
so that doesn't mean that the
cholesterol is there because people were
eating it.
Joel,
you know That could be though
that let.
Let's say,
let's look at what the research says
again here.
So they've done controlled feeding
studies where they fed people two to
four eggs a day and those show that in
75 percent of cases that has zero impact
on blood cholesterol levels for the
other 25 percent of people,
they're termed hyper responders and in
that group dietary cholesterol or does
modestly increase ldl cholesterol,
but it also increases hdl cholesterol
and it does not increase the risk of
heart disease.
This is why the guidelines were changed
on dietary cholesterol is there is no
evidence that they're consuming dietary
cholesterol increases the risk of blood
cholesterol and most people,
and even when it does,
there's no evidence that it increases
the risk of a heart attack,
which is again why the dietary
guidelines change for saturated fat.
Again,
it most of the studies that showed harm
work,
short term studies,
these longer term studies have shown
that on average eating saturated fat
does not increase saturated fat levels
in the blood and have all of the long
term studies that looked at this.
Only one showed any association between
saturated fat intake and cholesterol
levels in the blood.
Then we have a med analysis,
lots of meta analyses actually,
but one of the best known met analysis
was of 17 randomized controlled trials
of low carb diets that were high in
saturated fats in published in the
journal of obesity reviews,
and they found that low carb diets
neither increase nor decrease ldl
cholesterol,
but what they did find was that low carb
diets are associated with decrease in
body weight improvements in several
cardiovascular risks.
Risk factors including triglycerides,
fasting glucose,
blood pressure,
body mass index,
abdominal circumference,
plasma,
insulin,
c reactive protein,
as well as an increase in hdl
cholesterol.
Now,
there hAve now been 10 meta analysis of
randomized controlled trials looking at
low carb diets for weight loss.
all 10 showed that the low carb diet
either outperformed in most cases or was
was on this at the same level as low fat
diets.
There have been several metta analyses
now you can see them all at [inaudible]
dot com slash rogan that have looked at
a low carb diets for diabetes and
cardiovascular risk markers and all of
these meta analyses have found that low
carb diets are superior for glycaemic
control,
for reducing insulin,
for reducing triglycerides,
and have beneficial effects across the
board without increasing cardiovascular
risk markers.
So we're now we're talking about
randomized control trials,
which is the best form of evidence that
we have and we're not seeing any harm
from ink,
you know,
increased consumption of saturated fat.
So it was the problem that you're citing
epidemiology studies from the 19 forties
in the 19 fifties was that definitely.
I think we need to to to prefer
randomized controlled trials over that
kind of evidence for sure.
Why do you continue to go back to these
studies from the 1940 and 19 fifties was
beginning though the beginning,
but chris just took 14 topics and put
them into one for meta analysis during
them as controls.
The low carb,
low fat.
I mean they're all different topics and
I don't know how you put that all
together.
You need clarity and laser focused.
So we were talking saturated fat.
I mean,
so hypothesis has generated saturated
fat in the diet.
Butter,
eggs and cheese may be bad for heart
disease,
something killing americans left to
right in 1949 slash 50.
Let's go into countries with widely
different diets.
Let's see what they're eating.
Let's actually take their frigging diet
back to minneapolis.
Let's analyze it so it's not guessing.
Not food frequency questionnaires were
taking their meals back.
The United States analyze them,
but boom,
there's a relationship between dietary
saturated fat and your risk.
Fifty year followup,
there's no short term followup.
The study I'm referring to as 50 year
1958 to now and um,
that strongly suggested that dietary
saturated fat and heart disease that
doesn't,
that's not what's called the ultimate
randomized clinical study,
but it's one of high quality second
study done in China at the same time
with years of followup.
So these are right up to date.
There's publications right now from
studies starting at then,
but the publications are now,
but then you get the best kind of study.
Okay,
I'm still unsaturated saturated fat.
I'm not talking any other topic.
You put people in a metabolic ward at
the national institute of health,
395 of these studies published in 1979.
You change their diet.
This is the ultimate careful experiment.
It might be for four weeks or six weeks,
you up their saturated fat.
Their cholesterol rises assures can be,
we're all different.
The change in cholesterol is consistent.
You're going to go up 20 percent,
20 percent,
20 percent.
We start at different points.
You have to track the change in
clusteral.
Chris referred tO.
Can I go off on a tangent?
It's really interesting,
this will fascinate your listeners,
but it's right on the topic.
Two thousand and eight.
This is published data.
I don't bullshit on this.
Two thousand eight Mexico city,
the national,
the international dairy council meet and
they published their notes,
which is why we know this and they said
we are losing the battle.
People are eating less dairy around the
world and we are losing sales.
Well,
we can do is influence researchers
influence expeditions,
insistent speaker.
Well,
it's every.
Every dairy council in the world just
happens to meet in Mexico city that
year.
Then they go meet and Portugal.
Then they go meet in New York,
whatever,
2008.
We're going to put dollars into changing
research and influencing people.
doesn't mean it's all bad.
They publish those notes that are global
initiative for the next year.
They looked for sympathetic researchers
that would change public opinion and
that was right before the milk mustache
campaign.
They find a gUy I actually reSpect now,
but I'm going to beat them up a little.
Dr.
Ronald krauss,
md in berkeley,
California,
right by him runs it a liquid center.
He's had beef funding for 10 years.
He said dairy funding.
All of a sudden he's speaking to dairy
industries all over in 2010,
two years later,
he publishes,
we call it a meta analysis.
That's not new research,
that's statistical playing with previous
studies that can be fair,
can be unfair,
whatever.
Whatever it is,
their conclusion is they could not find
and verify that saturated fat in the
diet.
Butter,
eggs and cheese raises the risk of heart
disease.
they never said eat butter,
eggs and cheese.
They just couldn't verify what's
amazing.
It's an american journal of clinical
nutrition.
That same journal is a,
is a editorial that destroys the study.
This is 15 reasons.
This is horrible.
Epidemiology by guy named jeremiah
stamler.
I've never seen a medical journal
destroy a piece that they accepted for
publication.
Okay,
so everything's like stirred up and
2014,
a guy named chowdry publishes a similar
analysis.
That is the reason that time magazine
put on the cover butter is back because
it was not new research.
It's a meta analysis.
It's all following this Mexico city,
uh,
effort to a fund dairy positive
publications,
a study so bad that both the journal
required them to adjust and republish
the data because of mistakes.
The harvard school of public health
said,
take this thing away.
statistically.
This is nonsense.
Since those two times,
and that's just the bottom line,
we have had confusion in the public.
We've got experts like chris experts
like me,
experts like dr mark hyman,
experts like Dr.
Walter willett audit on.
There is a quote from the tobacco
industry that our product is confusion.
They didn't care about,
you know,
winning the battle when the is confused
or just going to keep on doing habits
they haVe.
And that has got to stop because now
we're in the weeds with conspiracy
theories to saturate so that when the
pendulum of 1950,
19,
69,
97,
395 of the best done studies in the
world,
say you eat more saturated fat,
your cholesterol goes up,
more saturated fat,
coronary heart disease goes up.
It was clear,
crystal clear in the guidelines,
set the guidelines.
Still say it.
The guidelines still say limits what the
same science from the 19 fifties in the
19 forties is applicable today.
If it's in retrospect,
valid there.
Let's point out one,
two.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Do you think it is?
Absolutely.
Why?
Because just bringing this up,
we're
going back to observational studies done
50,
60 years ago that suffer from all of the
problems that I mentioned to begin with
and several more that we didn't have
time to go into.
Um,
we have randomized controlled trialS now
and you know,
observational studies were never meant
to prove a hypothesis.
They're meant to generate a hypothesis
and it's true that in some cases it's
not possible to do a randomized
controlled trial,
like with cigarette smoking,
you'd have to have the trial lasts for
so long and you'd have to isolate people
and award so they weren't exposed to air
pollution and other factors that can
affect the result.
You can't do that.
But in that case the risk was a thousand
to 3000 percent higher.
So there are criteria called the
bradford hill criteria,
which yOu can use and apply to
observational studies to assess the
chance that there's a causal
relationship,
and in the case of smoking,
which actually was when the bradford
bradford hill criteria were created,
that really that meets many of those
criteria in the case of nutrition
research,
very seldom did they meet more than a
couple of the bradford hill criteria.
Now observational research in order to
be valuable and needs to be confirmed,
you know the results need to be
replicated in a randomized controlled
trial.
That's how science is supposed to work.
But there was one analysis that found
that zero of 52 claims that were made in
observational nutrition studies were
replicated when they were tested later
and in fact,
five were replicated in the opposite
direction.
In other words,
they did an experiment.
They found the opposite results of what
the observational studies suggested.
So a good examples of this are
obserVational studies originally
suggested that beta carotene,
an antioxidant that people with the
highest intake of beta carotene,
that's something like a 30 percent
reduced risk of death,
which is not really plausible anyways,
but then when they started doing trials
where they were giving people beta
carotene,
sUpplements,
not only did it not improve their
lifespan,
they got more cancer,
it increased the risK of cancer.
So this is why it's so important not to
rely just on observational data and to
do these experiments.
Now going back to saturated fat,
as I said,
we've got a 2013 meta analysis of
randomized controlled trials that found
that low carb,
high protein diets lead to greater
improvements in glycaemic control
compared to low fat american heart
association,
american diabetic association diets.
We've got a 2014 meta analysis of
randomized controlled trials that showed
that low carb diets are more effective
than high carb diets for patients with
type two diabetes.
And we've got another meta analysis of
25 randomized controlled trials just
published in 2018 that found the same
thing.
So you know,
science marches on,
we,
we learn more,
we change and now we've got randomized
controlled trials that are replacing
some of the observational evidence from
the fifties and sixties and seventies,
which,
which by the way in and dr hark homes
paper,
you see that that evidence was never
strong to begin with and this is what we
should be looking at.
So why are you consistently bringing up
these studies for fifties?
Because chris has mixing everything up.
He's talking low carb data.
Let's talk low carb diet.
That's kito diet low carb you,
you consistently bring up these studies
from the 19 fifties.
The 19 sixties diets are high in
saturated fat.
Okay?
Nineteen 50,
96 was the initiation.
Nineteen 97.
Clark 395 randomized clinical trials.
What chris looking for in metabolic
ward?
Say you jack up the saturated fat in
your diet.
You jack up your cholesterol.
We can talk about cholesterol in a
minute,
but cholesterol matters.
Ldl cholesterol matters in higher ed.
Ask asking a question.
You say 395 randomized controlled trials
in 1997.
Clark 1,907,
$395.
Met him off.
I'd love to see that different metabolic
wards day.
I can show you here.
It's right here.
I'll give you the rest of americans.
Ninety five.
He viewed 395,
a randomized controlled trials in a meta
analysis in metabolic ward.
the tightest dietary exchange studies,
the best sandwich would a metabolic
where it is,
but I don't understand the three 95.
That's how many were there.
Five people now.
Three hundred 95 individual studies that
played with fat content had died.
It looked at markers of cardiovascular
risks.
395 metabolic ward studies that were
randomized,
randomized controlled trials in
metabolic wards.
Yeah,
they're going to be short term.
That's true.
You've got to read the literature.
It's there.
I've read the literature while you
missed that one.
That's a pretty important.
Okay,
but let's go back,
but hold on a second.
This is a dispute here,
right?
So what is your issue with.
I'll just give you.
It's no big deal.
I'll give chris what is your issue?
I'm not aware of 300.
90 five randomized controlled trials
that have been done in a metabolic ward
on this question,
so I'd love to learn more about that if
that's true.
One second.
It's clark,
but so I mean I'm not stuck in the 19
fifties,
but you know,
if you don't agree,
right,
that science has moved far past that and
our understanding of nutrition and our
understanding of the mechanisms of the
effect of the food and the body.
All that has changed radically
are we have not changed our flipcharts
exchange,
but that's not what I asked you as our
understanding of the science change as
well.
Actually I would say that the
observations made in the fifties and
sixties if I held up,
which is why 21 international societies,
they'll say you will have held up that
low saturated fat in the diet.
Chicken,
eggs,
cheese,
beef is related to raising your
cholesterol is related to your increased
risk of heart attacks,
strokes,
19 fifties,
initial initial.
Then we got randomized clinical trials.
Those are called metabolic ward studies
and such.
The first,
the first chink in the,
in the armor was a 2010.
I gave you the background to it,
the siri torino study,
the [inaudible] study,
but they have been resolved.
We've decided to throw out 50 years of
science,
just mentioned several other med
analyses of I know,
probably a 50 randomized controlled
trials collectively here.
and these are
modern studies.
So joel,
what is the difference?
Like what,
why,
why do you think that these old studies
are applicable and why you dismissing
this new evidence?
okay,
so I just,
just so chris and I can resolve this
issue.
British medical journal in 1997,
dietary lipids and blood cholesterol.
Three hundred 95 individual dietary
experience,
uh,
put together in a med analysis.
It's a classic study that people know
they actually estimated if we could
lower the saturated fat content of the
british population by 60 percent and we
would save x number of heart attacks.
What year?
Nineteen 97.
So to answer your question,
why do I think old studies are relevant?
You have to keep probing and questioning
and probing and questioning.
But until this date,
every major medical society,
not one.
If there'S one you'd question at 21,
international sizes say you will further
the populace health.
If you lower saturated fat in the diet
and we can't pinpoint the amount of
cholesterol you should lower,
which is only from animal sources,
but you should lower it to as low as
possible.
According to the usda epidemiology
studies,
this was randomized data.
It's random.
It's based on.
And the guidelines have changed,
uh,
as,
as we said in 2010,
the new evidence,
there's new evidence is the new science,
like whatever they've studied today,
like what,
what the better methods of detection,
more,
more understanding,
more data to go from.
Wouldn't you agree that we should look
at new studies?
We should,
let me tell you say so wait,
let me tell you,
when I published a study in 2012,
that's when quoted 100,000
times for a major medical journal.
It uses something called men delian
randomization.
We don't need to do randomized clinical
trials all the time.
There are these gigantic databases now
about genetic abnormalities and certain
other parameters.
So there is a database with 300,000
people.
We know what's called their snips.
You've probably heard of snips,
you know chris is biology and jeans
aren't the same as mine,
and there's variability if you're born
with one of nine snips that keeps your
cholesterol low your entire life.
This is a genetic gift to you.
The observation in this major study
quarter all over the world,
first author is brian ferentz,
but I'm there.
Number five,
ldl randomization is new data that it is
an advantage for your survival and
advantage,
your risk of heart attack,
stroke to have a low ldl,
your whole life.
New data.
Is it consistent with 60 years of
science,
but boom,
it sure was.
We actually have learned stuff that has
changed our mind when you do that same
cutting edge science on hdl,
the happy one,
the high one.
You cannot show the same association
anymore.
We're totally confused by the hdl.
Particle ldl is the focus of
atherosclerosis low ldl,
and I'll just finish dr loren cordain.
I'd love to talk about the history of
the paleo movement.
Dr loren cordain,
who at the first popular book,
a phd in Colorado,
has written an article in 2004.
It says the ideal ldl cholesterol is 50
to 70.
Well man,
he should be a cardiologist because I'm
going to hug them for that because he
thought that saturated fat raises your
blood cholesterol,
increases your risk of heart attack and
stroke.
This is the founding pillars.
This 2004 and a big isn't a medical
journal.
I mean this is peer reviewed.
It was an editorial,
but it's peer review of 50 to 70 ldl.
I'm really cool there with loren cordain
and 50 to 78,
but our understanding of nutrition is
advanced pretty radically since I'm not.
Yeah.
And I'm not here to represent paleo.
I mean,
I never been,
uh,
ideological about paleo.
Even if you read my first book,
I'm recommending dairy products,
but I don't want to get lost in this
because you pause for a second.
So what is your response though to all
these studies that he was citing?
You're citing these old studies that
seem to contradict what he saying,
but these new studies that he showing
and you could,
we can go over them again,
but you didn't address.
You did
well,
he didn't say saying them by name.
What?
Why are the results so different than
the new studies?
Oh,
well people better at statistics than me
with say manipulation of what's called
meta analysis.
These aren't new studies.
I mean these are old studies lumped
together with different analyses that
led to a conclusion that was accurate.
These are.
These are randomized controlled trials
that are long term.
That's 20 years,
30 years,
40 years.
There is no such show.
Of course they're not doing 20 or 30 or
40 year randomized controlled trial.
We have fish.
We have 50 year data on seven I'll study
of 50 years.
Problem
difference,
again we've already outlined is a big
difference between epidemiology studies
and randomized trial.
Randomized controlled trials are not
short term.
Many of them are go up to two years in
length.
If we're going to see changes in lipids,
we're going to see them within a few
weeks and certainly within a few months,
so if we're not seeing them in a few
months,
we're not going to see them later.
And you know the.
If you look at dr.
Hark homes paper,
she reviews all of the the meta analyses
and looking at saturated fat and the
connection with heart disease.
There are 39 med analyses of rcts or
prospective cohort studies that looked
at saturated fat and health outcomes.
Thirty five of 39 did not show
significant correlations between
saturated fat and any outcome.
Okay.
Thirty five of 39 of the four that did
one was more related to trans fats,
not saturated fats.
OnE showed a benefit of replacing
saturated fat with polyunsaturated fat,
but it excluded twO studies that would
have totally changed the result.
And as I mentioned,
there's the med analysis of 25 rcts and
40 observational studies that showed no
benefit of replacing saturated fat with
polyunsaturated fat.
And then the last two were cochrane
reviews.
And in those two,
saturated fat and cardiovascular disease
were correlated,
but saturated fat was not correlated
with total mortality,
cardiovascular disease mortality,
a fatal heart attack,
nonfatal heart attack,
stroke or a heart death from heart
disease or death from any diagnoses of
diabetes.
So joel,
I'm going to let you get you had out of
those 39 trials,
virtually none showed that eating
saturated fat will increase your risk of
heart disease and none showed that it
will increase your risk of death from
any cause.
So that is pretty damning evidence.
Now,
if I could summarize for you or get you
to summarize your position,
is that his reciting of these older
studies that they are not relevant,
that they are epidemiologists,
study that they are,
they are not as rigorous and that this
new evidence is based on a new
understanding and new science and that
he's ignoring this.
Yeah,
the early studies showed some
relationship,
but they were short,
very short term between eating saturated
fat and then and then cholesterol.
The other problem is they were using
cholesterol as a proxy marker.
They weren't looking at did people eat
saturated fat and die more?
They'd looked at did saturated fat,
inCreased cholesterol.
Um,
so when they,
when they did longer term studies,
there's no increase in cholesterol on
average.
That doeSn't mean no one will experience
an increase.
That's not true.
Some people will,
but on average there was no increase in.
And then when they looked at they just
took cholesterol out of the equation.
Let's just look at is there an increase
in heart attacks or death from eating
saturated fat when they did that?
There's no increase in [inaudible].
These are that,
those are observational studies and we
have all these randomized controlled
trials that are showing no,
no increase in cholesterol,
no increase in insulin levels and
actually a decrease in all of those
markers.
Joel,
um,
important stuff.
And a lot of stuff was said.
And I doubt it,
unless you're really high level,
you understood.
I just want to pick out one thing chris
said,
does anybody know what the cochrane
database?
So where'd the flow of his mouth?
Cochran coc,
h r n e is a group of scientists to try
and be very objective,
very independent,
don't have any emotional,
any books,
any supplements,
any food,
and nothing,
and we all love supplements around this
table,
but let's get out of that cochrane
database.
Every five years,
comes out with a statement that
saturated fat relate to the risk of
heart disease.
In 2015,
the most recent hooper look up hooper
lookup cochrane database.
YeS it does.
Chris said it,
but he flew by it.
No,
it wasn't powerful enough that your
choice of butter,
eggs,
meat,
and cheese necessarily predicted your
total lifespan,
but it absolutely predicted your risk of
developing a heart attack and stroke
according to this independent david.
How 2015.
Well,
how does it do it?
Saturated fat in the diet lowers the ldl
receptor.
Gene liver.
Let's talk some real science.
Your liver,
my liver.
Chris's liver.
When you don't have ldl receptors or
less than you should on the surface of
your liver cells,
you ldl stays in your blood.
it gets into your arterial wall.
That's my field.
Don't jack with manner,
tara walls.
It gets picked up by monocytes and
macrophages become foamy cells and you
fucking dead,
and that's how it starts.
When you eat saturated fat,
there's a chain of events that
biologists and chemists and scientists
know.
There's no question.
Nineteen 85 nobel prize in medicine.
Nobody would not go to the eighties.
Again.
When you go to these studies,
just want you to refute,
okay,
2012,
I published a study which one of us is
as scientists around the table.
I've got it open.
It's a journal,
american kind of high energy may please
read the conclusion,
the lower your ldl level beginning in
life,
the greater issue.
Reduction in your risk of developing a
heart attack and stroke,
and I'll give you an interesting
statistic.
If you take lipitor and you drop your
ldl cholesterol 30 percent,
you will typically drop your risk of a
heart attack.
If you're in the coronary range by 30
percent.
If you drop your ldl by 30 percent
because you're born with a genetic gift,
that it's just a lower than the average
american,
you drop your risk of heart attack by 90
percent.
When you keep your cholesterol down your
whole life.
I'm telling you,
your blood cholesterol level,
your whole life,
you are golden and the heart attack and
stroke risk.
The problem was they do.
We pick up people at age 50,
60 and we start jaclyn with her diet and
jacket with their drugs and that's
wonderful.
They've had 50,
60 years of deteriorating their arteries
and we help them.
We can't help them like teaching
children eat fruits and vegetables and
stay away from hot dogs.
That's where we got to go.
That's the second gong to get kids
healthy because they got their whole
life.
Please,
what is wrong with what he said?
Well,
there's.
There's illusions to what's the number
one,
two things wrong and I,
you know,
I'm really not trying to nitpick.
He doesn't like epidemiology,
but he totally uses epidemiology to
support his case.
You can't have it both ways.
I love basic biochemistry.
I love epidemiologists.
I love randomized studies,
I love sitting there and in studies,
my foundation is broad and it's what's
called the scientific method that's used
by scientists and los angeles,
and that's taught me a number two.
Uh,
besides that,
there's,
there's illusions to significant
randomized clinical trials in meta
analysis.
We got to keep the science clean as can
be.
A breakthrough has been the meta
analysis.
Siri torino chowdry 2010,
2014 d'souza,
thousand 15.
They haVe severe flaws.
They're not new research.
They're rehashing old data.
There has not been a randomized clinical
trial that really challenges the
coronary heart disease risk or meaning
and increased saturated fat that you
three right now.
So long are they?
Hold on.
There is american journal of clinical
nutrition,
2013.
I'm a judge or holla.
I'm not sure how to pronounce the name.
These are all on my website.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com slash
research,
you can see them or crestor.com/rogan,
and you scroll down to the saturated fat
section.
You can see them.
This is a total of 20 randomized
controlled trials and the results low
carb load,
gi,
mediterranean,
and high protein diets are effective in
improving various markers of
cardiovascular risk and people with
diabetes should be considered the
overall strategy of diabetes management.
And then we've got a one from a snore
guard,
systematic review and meta analysis of
dietary carbohydrate restriction in
patients witH type two diabetes.
And this was a review of 10 rcts and
they found not only was the low carb
diet more effective for diabetes than
the low fat diet,
the greater the carbohydrate
restriction,
the greater the effect.
And then we have one from 2018.
This is sainsbury at all and this is
effective dietary carbohydrate
restriction on glycemic control in
adults with diabetes.
And they found that the low carb,
uh,
the conclusion,
this review suggests that low carb
restricted or carbohydrate restricted
diets could be offered to people livinG
with diabetes as part of an
individualized management plan.
So these are finding that these,
these are,
you know,
reviews of several randomized controlled
trials that are finding that there's no
increase in cardiovascular risk markers.
There's actually an improvement in
cardio vascular risk markers and there's
an improvement in diabetes markers like
blood sugar,
insulin weight,
visceral fat,
et cetera.
So I mean this is the,
the,
the gold standard of evidence that we
have is randomized controlled trials and
meta analyses.
Of course they do.
They're,
there are problems.
They can be done poorly.
They can be done well.
That's true of any kInd of scientific
research,
but we can't throw out really the
highest standard of evidence is a meta
analysis of randomized controlled trials
because you can just.
Anyone can pick one randomized
controlled trial to support their view.
The met analysis does is it looks at all
of the evidence and it looks at the
quality of evidence and then it comes up
with a result from looking at all of
these trials and that's,
that's where science is today and these
low carb diets are high in saturated
fat.
They are high in saturated fat.
Yeah.
Unless they're explicitly doing a trial
where they're doing a low carb diet
that's the tire and mono unsaturated
fat,
but those are rare.
Generally,
people who are reading low carb diets or
eating a lot more saturated fat.
Joel,
just three quick bullet points.
Number one,
it is low carb literature.
We're talking saturated fat and coronary
disease.
That's a mixture.
It's not the topic we're talking about.
Number two,
these are buying at the top of that.
We're talking about low carbs,
a whole different nutritional.
That's that.
We haven't seen it.
That's what he said.
Yeah,
no,
you can do low carbon jack up protein,
but most of the experts say,
don't do that.
That's called meat.
You can do low carbon jack up fat.
That doesn't necessarily mean you're
jacking up your saturated fat.
I do low carb plant based.
That's a whole different topic,
but it is not the number one.
These are one.
It's low carb.
It's not the main topic that's dominated
cardiovascular research for 60 years,
which is consistent to this day in every
guideline.
Limit saturated fat.
She don't die of a heart attack.
Stroke number two,
I just.
These are words your listeners may not
know.
These seats that our biomarker studies,
I'm talking about dying of heart
attacks,
having heart attacks,
having stroke.
I care if your blood sugar marker called
hemoglobin a,
one c goes down.
I care if your ldl and your high
sensitivity c reactive protein goes
down,
but that's not life and death.
Those are biomarkers,
so usually correlated with better
health.
If you're not tracking in artery,
you're not in my scientific field
because I track arteries in clinic,
we track arteries in our research
studies.
Um,
I think that's the second thing I wanted
to say,
but you know,
I'm not here to actually negate the data
that compared the crappy calorie rich
and process died.
The most americans are eating what chris
is presenting as alternative diet won't
improve numbers in the lab.
Absolutely.
It's a better choice.
I like your diet.
I do.
Joe.
I like your diet,
chris,
because I'm looking at people walking in
wendy's and hardee's and mcdonald's and
hospital cafeterias and gas stations.
That's what we need to shut down and
we'll make a main difference at all
we're left with is chris's diet,
joe's diet and joel's diet.
We're going to have an amazing country.
Then you can decide what you want.
I think we all agree with that,
but I still need to bring you back to
this,
what he's talking about in terms of
saturated fat and not being a risk and
not increasing your cholesterol.
You seem to disagree with that.
Sure.
Because the science says it does.
I mean,
he just said,
I would say that it doesn't show me.
Let me clarify something too.
I wasn't.
I'm not just talking about biomarkers.
Biomarkers are important,
but I was the one who argued for looking
at total mortality is the most important
endpoint and mortality for many of these
other diseases and for the conclusion
from Dr.
Hart comes paper where she reviewed all
of the evidence on saturated fat that I
talked about before and I just mentioned
35 of 39 studies didn't show any
relationship.
Here's the conclusion.
No meta analysis of randomized
controlled trials and slash or
prospective cohort studies.
Those are observational studies,
has found any significant difference for
dietary fat interventions and all cause
mortality.
That's deaths from any cause or death
from heart disease or associated with
dietary fat and heart disease mortality.
In other words,
there's no med analysis of randomized
controlled trials that shows that eating
more saturated fat will will increase
your risk of death
and your take on this is that this is
the latest science and that would he
siting in terms of these studies from
the 19 fifties,
the 19 sixties aren't really relevant?
Yes,
and it that that,
but even even if we look at
epidemiology,
like I said earlier,
that there are.
There's a meta analysis of studies
including 350,000
participants that found no relationship
between saturated fat intake and
cardiovascular disease and then a more
recent review that included both
randomized controlled trials,
25 of them and 40 observational studies
with 650,000
participants that that concluded.
Current evidence doesn't clearly support
cardiovascular guidelines that encourage
high consumption of polyunsaturated fat
and low consumption of pto of saturated
fat.
So whether you look at the epidemiology
or whether you look at the randomized
controlled trials are the meta analysis
of randomized controlled trials.
You ended up in the same place,
joel,
most modern data,
we already talked this,
everyBody please google cochrane
database saturated fat.
Two thousand 15 hooper is the author.
He the introduction is reducing
saturateD fat,
reduces serum cholesterol,
but we're not sure of the importance.
So we took 15 randomized studies with
59,000
participants.
The conclusion there is a potentially
important reduction in heart disease
risk by reducing saturated fat in your
diet.
Two thousand 15,
which is why 21 international societies
are solid that we will help the public.
We will help the listeners have your
piece of meat,
make it four ounces,
not 14 ounces,
have your bake and make a one strip,
not for strips.
Have your cheese,
just don't eat it every day and don't
eat large amounts.
The amount of cheesy United States has
gone insane because the usta funds
cheese manufacturers.
Okay,
so 2015.
I can't get you a better one though.
They'll update cochrane database in 20
slash 20.
It'll be the same.
What's your take on when you said so?
Here's johnny.
I don't care.
Honestly what he said,
I've got to go with the best science in
the world because I deal with patients
who have serious disease.
I can tell my patients the most updated
data analysis of randomized clinical
studies say saturated fat in your diet
raises your cholesterol,
lowering saturated fat,
like eating less animal products,
not the most.
Up to date.
Two thousand 15 database mentioned to
several med analyses from 2008.
This is not been announced.
This is random as clinical studies.
Fifty 9,000
participants out there reviewing
studies.
That's not a that's and that's w.
We have to look at the weight of
evidence.
There are lots of studies published all
the time and that's again why looking at
med analyses of randomized controlled
trials,
looking at very large reviews of
observational studies with over a
million participants and you end up in
the same place.
Of course we can go and find one study
here,
one study there that that is different
has a different result,
but that's not the scientific method.
The scientific method is to look at the
weight of the evidence and to continue
to evaluate that over time as the
evidence changes.
And you know,
this is a great quote from johnny and
dennis,
the stanford epidemiologists that I
mentioned,
um,
that,
that reminds us that we can't just rely
on the past to inform the present.
He said claimed research findings may
often be simply accurate measures of the
prevailing bias.
And that what that means is that let's
say,
you know,
you haVe a paper that,
uh,
you know,
30,
40,
50 years ago that says saturated fat
increases the risk of cholesterol.
Then later somebody makes that claim and
a paper just like that initial sentence,
saturated fat raises cholesterol.
You see a little number,
they're referencing that one paper.
Then a couple of years later,
somebody else makes that same claim.
They referenced the second paper which
was referencing the first paper and on
and on it goes.
And the whole thing is a house of cards.
That's what most people don't realize
that that is bad science.
This was good side.
The bad side is what you're saying.
You're saying you see what he's saying
is because we know not.
Again,
he's making comments that have no
reference shortly.
If there's misquoted the references.
CAn I give an example?
How does he have no references?
A scientific peer reviewed paper that
quoted or referenced in everybody's
simply passively keeps requesting their
reference.
It was wrong in the beginning.
I can give you a real life internet
example wigs because gary dobbs,
my new friend,
but sometimes my adverse adversary,
but I can't give you a literature
reference.
It might be one,
but these are very general statements.
I just want to.
I think we should
move on,
but no,
I definitely shouldn't because we're not
really clearing this up.
What is he saying that's wrong?
Okay.
The best scientific analysis of the
global topic to saturated fat.
Rich containing foods which are animal
sourced foods at high amount in your
diet,
increase your risk of dying of a heart
attack or stroke or have a heritage.
Stroke goes to the biochemistry,
etc.
Offend your diet,
will lower the number of ldl receptors
on your liver and your blood close to it
goes up.
That's backed by 395 metabolic ward
studies,
but that is biochemistry.
Then you get to epidemiology countries
that eat more saturated fat.
Finland.
Great story,
and I got to tell it,
1970.
The highest heart attack rate in the
world was Finland.
Guys were dying your age and my age at
the highest rate,
the lowest heart attack rate in the
mediterrAnean was crete.
Forty percent of calories from fat and
Finland.
crete.
Is that.
How can that happen?
Because I'm not an advocate for low fat
diet except for very selected clinical
cases.
IT was olive oil and crete.
That's very low,
not zero low in saturated fat.
It was cheese,
it was meat,
it was beef,
it was butter in Finland.
They instituted a national program to
lower the content,
has saturated fat in the diet and
Finland.
five years later,
hard tech dropped 80 percent.
Kevin,
do you understand that?
He's.
He's saying something totally different.
You're citing epidemiologist chemistry.
Then I went to epic.
What's wrong with what he said,
because he's not being broad with the
scientist
getting.
He's getting mired in the woods.
I'm telling you,
the broadest view from 50,000
feet up,
biochemistry supports it.
Epidemiology supports at 395 metabolic
ward studies,
my randomized mendelian randomization so
said though,
because he's not looking at the entirety
of the data and I'm telling you the
entire data.
Then you'd go to loma linda,
okinawa,
you go to [inaudible],
you'd go to Costa Rica and you go to
sardinia.
If you are live to 100 and you're still
operating on somebody's heart is you're
likely high in animal saturated fat or
not.
The answer is it isn't.
It's as low as three percent of the diet
and okay,
what could it possibly be?
other faculty user bias that.
There's a great stat recently that came
out that showed that just following the
top five health behaviors which are
basic,
so we're talking about not smoking,
not drinking,
maintaining a healthy body weight,
getting some physical activity and
eating healthy.
You know,
relatively healthy diet,
like not junk all the time.
Increases your lifespan by 13 years and
that's where you cannot.
You can't look at these at these
populations and make inferences about
animal products being the driving factor
one way or the other because there's
just too many other factors.
There's no way to control for all of
those factors in a study and that's why
we have to come back to the scientific
method.
We use observational studies to come up
with hypotheses.
Then we do randomized controlled trials
to either confirm or refute those
hypotheses.
As I said before,
in many cases,
what is apparent and observational
studies or what seems apparent to is not
later confirmed in randomized controlled
trials.
And that's where we're at now wIth
saturated fat and dietary cholesterol.
I just mentioned three very large meta
analysis of randomized controlled trials
that failed to confirm any association
of saturated fat and heart disease and,
or saturated fat and increase in these
risk markers.
And I mentioned to reviews of very large
observational study data including
350,000
in one study in 650 in another showing
no relationship.
So the mechanistic arguments about
liver,
you know,
the saturated fat does this or that,
uh,
that's not convincing.
If it's not showing up in the data,
if it did that,
then we would see it in the
observational studies in the randomized
studies.
Now,
specifically joel,
what is your take on what he just said?
Well,
we just had another gang moment,
so chris just quoted and it's actually a
little bit comical,
a harvard school of public health study
on how do you live 14 years longer.
It's epidemiology,
but he's using it until the senior
author is Dr.
Walter willett.
A guy he calls a vegan pro,
uh,
advocate who's not at all vegan.
He's written a book about the
mediterranean diet with all kinds of
animal recipes in it,
which is fine with me.
He's a brilliant,
brilliant,
brilliant senior harvard researcher,
but she's using data that he says is
weakened such,
yet the teaching point is there.
How do you live 14 years longer?
You don't smoke exercise 30 minutes a
day.
He eat better than average.
That's very broad,
but you'd better than average.
You,
um,
keep your waist under 25,
a bmi under 25 and you have a few
alcoholic beverages a week.
I want your listeners to write that down
because that is solid epidemiologic data
that's fairly consistent across across
the spectrum.
So let's all use something to teach your
listeners,
but that's my point.
So you can't look at cultures that have
a completely different lifestyle than
standard american lifestyle and draw any
inferences about animal products.
So a really good example of this is,
you know,
the seventh day adventists,
uh,
the,
the claim is that it's the vegetarian
diet that makes them live longer than
the general population,
but they,
as I mentioned before,
as part of their belief system,
they don't smoke,
they don't drink,
they have a healthy lifestyle in
general.
What if there was another population
that also had those kinds of belief
systems about not smoking,
not drinking and healthy lifestyle,
but they also ate meat.
Well,
turns out there is the mormons and
there've been three studies on mormons
and each of the mormon,
the studies had been done on mormons,
found that they're mortality.
I'll give you the exact numbers here in
just a second.
Um,
for whatever reason that's not coming up
here.
But um,
their risk of death compared to the
general population was something like 50
percent lower than the general
population on average and yet they're
eating animal foods.
They're not vegetarian like the seventh
day adventist.
So
point and bringing that epidemiologists
study in the first place,
bringing up healthy lifestyle,
increasing your lifespan by 14 years is
to show that any positive move is going
to show whether it's just exercise and
not eating sugar or whatever is going to
show an increase in,
in your lifespan.
Yeah,
and just to show how hard it is to
isolate single variables and the
influence of those single variables in
an observational study on,
on those effects,
and this is something that you noticed
johnny geneticists said over and over
again,
is that it's almost impossible if not
impossible to disentangle the influences
of all of these single variables in
observational research.
And again,
I'm not saying we shouldn't use
observational research.
I'm saying we should be circumspect
about how you use it and we should be
aware of the limitations and the flaws
and keep those in mind when we're
designing observational studies and when
we're interpreting their results.
So joe,
what is your opinion on what he's saying
about saturated fat and cholesterol and
mortality risk?
Okay.
Well,
I think I've said it,
but I'll repeat it.
I just want to point out we just shared
another common moment.
We're both lifestyle medicine doctors of
which nutrition is just one part.
We just went through a list of lifestyle
factors.
We now add sleep,
we had social support,
we had stress management skills.
It's not all smoking diet,
exercise and and the size of your body,
but we are aligned and in know and we
will go at patient's side by side and do
a lot of the exactly the same thing.
In fact,
I think the only thing they're squabble
about and lifestyle medicine is optimal
nutrition to prevent chronic disease and
there's probably more than one path,
but god knows the plant based medicine
group has a tremendous body of science.
I'll conclude one more time and I don't
know how many times I can say at the
highest level of science to integrate
all that's available biochemistry's on
the side.
Saturated fat raises your risk of
coronary heart disease.
It doesn't mean nobody eats a no
saturated fat diet,
but you can lower it.
A observational studies where their
epidemiology studies were to test that
hypothesis.
They confirm Finland and crete I've
talked about.
I won't go there.
Again.
Randomized clinical trials have
confirmed it.
Hooper cochrane database 2015.
My study 2012,
widely cited worldwide has confirmed it.
Get your ldl cholesterol down
genetically or by diet as long as you
can,
as early as you can,
and finally in the last is what a old
healthy people do.
Actually,
chris,
I just think there's a good concept to
let your listeners know.
It isn't all about lifespan.
In fact,
lifespan,
the united is dropping,
which is very scary for all the frigging
money we spend on health.
There's something called health span,
which is to avoid chronic disease and
die dancing or die,
swimming or die sky diving,
but don't die in a frigging hospital
with a peg tube and a trake and a and a
foley up your,
uh,
who,
and um,
many of these studies that show you can
reduce your risk of heart disease,
stroke and diabetes are talking about
better quality of life.
So when you put all that together,
these centenarian studies that have low
saturated fat diets are just one more
piece I just mentioned for incredibly
solid piece of evidence.
Not one,
it's for,
it's all that's out there.
It's what nobel prize winners use when
they describe the cholesterol hypothesis
is what is this correct?
He may not know it.
In this city of los angeles,
our shared friend,
dr valter longo often considered,
and you should have on the show perhaps
the world's leading expert in nutrition,
longevity and such.
We'll say you incorporate all the bases
for nutritional evaluation.
You keep it big picture.
You don't that he calls it pixel
mentality.
You don't get hung up on one study.
You get the whole picture biochemistry,
epidemiology,
randomized clinical trials.
finally centenarian studies.
I think it's very consistent.
You will enhance your health by lowering
animal based products.
Now we can argue is that 70 percent,
80 percent,
90 percent plant based loren cordain and
uh,
the founder of the paleo movement,
um,
boyd eaton,
we were talking about 70 percent plants
on your plate.
I love that.
You know,
I'm not telling people quit eating meat
today or thy,
I'm not a reactionary,
but to say that plant based medicine
doesn't have a strong basis that I can't
reverse plaque which just plant based
medicine.
We haven't even talked about the ability
to do that,
but iS his absolute heresy because it in
fact is one of the most powerful piece
attrition we have.
Okay,
but what's wrong with these studies that
he's talking about their pixel
mentalities,
picking one,
know how observational data of over a
million people and three different meta
analyses of 20 to 25 randomized
controlled trials each pixel mentality.
This is the gold standard for assessing
a question like this in medicine.
It's not mechanistic data or mechanistic
arguments don't make,
are not persuasive if they don't
translate into real outcomes that you
can measure in randomized controlled
trials or observational studies like
trying to boil this down.
So what is your take on that without any
references to the past and people that
lived in Angola that live longer.
These are the three disruptive
randomized trials from 2010 on that
question.
The relationship.
Those are different trials,
joel.
Well then these are three different
trials.
I'm not the crosses researcher or
chowder worries you.
You need to.
You need to throw them out there and let
us know the reference I did before.
You want me to do it again?
No,
but we will get my yard.
I mean,
what is wrong with what he's saying?
I'm just look at them.
Obviously the non expert here and I'm
baffled.
So I'm trying to boil this down with his
little rhetoric as possible.
Okay.
It
a heretical conspiracy attitude to say
everybody's got it wrong for 60 years.
Twenty one international societies have
rung.
They could,
but it's a controversy theory to say
that,
um,
hooper cochrane database,
2015,
they've got it wrong,
that metabolic ward studies got it
wrong.
This is one or two or three pieces of
data and their observational,
you don't throw out the babies with the
benefit randomized controlled trials
saying they're observational if they're
not.
What men analysis by nature is implying.
It's not a new study.
it's taking previous studies in doing
so.
Let me give you one quick example.
In the chowdry meta analysis created
butter is back on the cover of time
magazine created a whole fervor out
there that we can go back to and all
these great foods that atkins wants us
to eat.
They correlated your blood cholesterol
with your risk of having heart disease.
They couldn't confirm it.
Well,
they allowed people in that men analysis
who are on lipitor,
well,
of course you're on a medicine,
lowers your cholesterol.
They didn't exclude those people.
That has been resoundingly criticized
as,
yes,
it looks good.
It's in a journal.
It's a meta analysis that is fraudulent
or at least relatively inappropriate
statistics.
It's,
you know,
it's,
it's so technical,
it's beyond,
I think,
the importance of this discussion,
but I just say 50,000
feet elevation view of the best
nutrition is again,
four pillars that I keep talking about
indicates you'd be very wise to limit
the amount of saturated fat and that's
endorsed by every major medical society
in the world.
It's not controversial.
I don't.
I don't think it's conspiracy.
I think it's just the natural
progression of science.
When we used to think the world was
flat,
but that's theirs were caused by stress,
but that's down there.
There are a lot of things that have
changed over time as the evidence
evolves and is we'd be.
We become more educated and aware of
some sort of a belief in a conspiracy.
Well,
chris is suggesting we got it wrong,
which means the american heart,
american college,
the world health institute of medicine,
the european society of atherosclerosis,
the australian society of health,
all of these bleep,
bolded,
tell you 10 percent or less saturated
fat.
Some say as little as you could possibly
get in your diet have got it wrong and
that suggests there's been a total
misrepresentation of all the sciences.
I paused for a second there.
What are their recommendations based on?
Is it based on old science?
No,
I mean these are long.
Have they been saying this and what is
it based on?
And have they adjusted to this new
science?
He's discussing [inaudible],
republican,
republican for the usta republishes
every five years.
Two thousand and 16.
Not long ago.
Five years.
Two thousand 16 was the last usd a
publication there.
We'll do it again in 20 slash 20.
But doesn't this science change?
Not that fast.
There's nothing new since 2000 took
theme that rocks the idea that 21
international got
it wrong there.
Nothing.
There isn't.
The 2015 report did not use.
Um,
there was a,
the usta setup,
the nutrition evidence library to help
conduct systemic reviews to answer some
of these questions.
And in the 2015 report,
the committee stated that it didn't use
that database for 70 percent of the
topics.
And um,
the,
a lot of the guidelines hadn't used any
newer science from since 2010 and there
had been large reviews as I just
mentioned,
these,
these three reviews that I mentioned,
one was in 2000,
13,
one was in 2017 and one was in 2018.
These are the reviews of the randomized
controlled trials that didn't show
increase in cardiovascular risk markers
from saturated fat consumption.
and then we had those observation
reviews of observational studies of
300,000,
650,000
people.
I think the same thing will happen with
saturated fat,
as I said in 2010,
they changed their recommendations on
total fat.
They used to limit total fat and then
they changed those in 2010,
2015,
they changed their recommendation on
dietary cholesterol.
And I think probably the next time,
you know,
maybe it's the next time or maybe it's
the time after that you'll see a change
in the saturated fat guidelines.
And it's not a big conspiracy.
I'm not saying,
you know,
it's not a conspiracy,
it's the advancement of science.
So your take is that these organizations
are behind the curve.
Yes.
And if we want to talk about conflicts
of interest,
there are huge conflicts of interest in
these organizations.
Something like 40 percent of the funding
of the uh,
uh,
well,
I don't want to get this number wrong,
but a lot.
The american heart association,
american diabetic association,
a lot of these organizations have
funding from big food.
Um,
you know,
coca cola,
you talked to a nutritionist who goes to
these conferences and they,
you know,
there's like nestle bars and coca cola
at the nutrition conferences.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
it's hilarious.
This terrible,
wasn't it?
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's actually funny and sad at the same
time.
And so I'm not saying there's a big
conspiracy,
but I am saying there's a problem in
terms of scientific integrity when you
have these organizations,
they're tasked with creating the
guidelines that have these financial
conflicts of interest.
That's not really how it should be,
but I don't,
I don't even want to go too far down
that road because we don't need to go
there in order to show that the
sciences,
what the,
what the science is showing and peer
review journals.
So joel,
what is wrong with what he just said?
Well,
I'll say this until 2020 usda guidelines
come in.
Actually think he's factually wrong
because he goes to a guideline,
say keep the percentage of calories from
saturated fat to 35 percent or less.
I could be wrong on that.
I'm not an encyclopedia.
I know they say,
oh,
I agree with that.
Well,
why?
I said they changed their total,
their
limitation on total fat in 2010.
And I,
I'm speculating that eventually changed
their guidelines on saturated fat
because the science has evolved and I
will buy you guys are all paid trip to
bali.
If you see in the 2020 guidelines that
saturated fat is still not to be limited
to that.
Right?
So what's wrong with what he said?
Uh,
I,
I don't know it just.
Well it's about.
I agree there are conflicts of funding,
but they're not unique to any particular
sector.
Um,
we just had one of the most famous food
psychologist in Connecticut.
Brian wants it goes.
A hero of mine,
said eden small plates because we
didn't.
SmAll plates.
You're mindful and you don't get obese.
had to have six papers rejected and had
to resign.
It's pervasive.
It's a problem.
Doesn't mean there's not been any good
scientists and I think most of the
people we've been talking about are
largely good scientists that their
reputation hasn't been tainted.
I don't want to get,
get too Mired in this,
but if you look at the egg industry
prior to 1990,
about 30 percent of egg studies on
nutrition,
we're funded by the egg board since
1990.
It's 92 percent.
It's a conflict.
Who's got the money to study nutrition?
It's not the broccoli grower stop you
because we're getting in the weeds
again.
What is wrong with what he said?
Well,
he's predicting that there'll be a
change in the record.
I think there's no,
there's no substantial new data on
saturated fat since 2015 hooper in 2016
usta.
That changes anybody to question that
they should not recognize and follow the
leadership of 21 international societies
that are out there to try and improve
the copy there because those 21
international societies and all these
different organizations,
they rely on current science to make the
recommendations correct?
sure,
sure.
Okay.
And are they often behind the curve?
I don't believe so.
The usda,
it goes through this whole presence now.
They haven't published anything new
since 2016.
It's an expensive process,
but they did change.
Like he said,
they're total fat requirements.
They did change what they believe to be
healthy and not healthy.
Um,
well said.
They changed it in 2010.
Correct.
It changed the limitation on total fat
in 2010 and then they changed the
limitation on dietary cholesterol in
2015.
So they admit that the sciences advanced
and changed their perceptions of what is
in and is not healthy.
So what's wrong with what he's saying
aBout saturated fat?
Uh,
they didn't chain saturated fat,
so if we stick just,
they're,
they,
they rely on the current science.
Right?
So he's saying that the current science
is showing that there is no negative
consequences of saturated fat.
That's bs,
that's bs.
So what is wrong with these studies that
he's citing?
Well,
I don't know.
I have not read every article in the
world,
nor has chris.
I don't know specifically.
There are three faMous studies that I've
read.
Siri,
torino,
chowdry and d'souza.
Those have been dissected.
Those are event generally,
but you don't believe the ones that he
cited?
Well,
I don't,
I don't know actually he would probably
those to support
his case,
but they've been so resoundingly
criticized that and they created fervor
and I'll,
I don't know this sounding,
said it criticized.
I'm aware that there has been criticism,
but you could say the same thing about
the vegetarian lifespan studies to the
I,
a arc report on processing
scientifically been debunked by any
stretch of the imagination.
They are the papers stand.
The authors have defended against those
criticisms.
And uh,
it's nothing like what joel was talking
about with brian wansink who had to re,
you know,
all the papers were proven to be
fraudulent and he had to retract them.
It's nothing like that that has happened
with those papers and those were not the
ones that I cited anyway.
Yeah.
I just want to say the usd in 2015 said
total fat intake should be 20 to 30 fiVe
percent of all your calories.
They didn't eliminate anything in 2010.
that's 2015.
I think that's a factual error,
chris.
They clearly change a cholesterol
recommendation to say as little as
possible.
They just didn't put a number on it.
We all know that my cardiology group
went bananas and got them to add that
sentence as keep cholesterol as low as
possible.
Chris,
it says cholesterol is no longer a
nutrient of concern,
but you were talking that they removed
the total fat intake.
That's actually inaccurate.
It's right here.
I mean,
I'm going to get the guideline open,
you know,
it is.
I mean,
we're,
we're allowed to make mistakes.
We're trying to incorporate the whole
world literature and we're just two
guys.
Was that a mistake,
chris?
Right here.
I mean,
it's a mistake.
This mistake.
What did he say?
That we said that in 2010,
the usda guidelines which are supposed
to be followed by schools and colleges
and the rest removed the total fat
percentage recommendation.
It remainS at 20 to thIrty five percent.
That's fairly modest fat intake.
I have to look at this,
the specific
language to see.
My recollection is that the,
in the same way that there is some,
a contradiction with the cholesterol.
There's a sentence that says cholesterol
is no longer a nutrient of concern.
And then joel mentioned that he and his
cardiologist friends got them to add
something back that was,
you know,
kind of seem to step back from that.
Um,
and I think the same thing happened with
total fat.
I don't know,
and I can't,
I don't have it to look at right now.
Can we?
This is so because it's,
it seems like it's a major point of
dispute and joel says it isn't.
It isn't because the the still the
question at hand is what do the meta
analysis of randomized controlled trials
and what do the reviews,
large reviews of observational studies,
including over a million participants
suggest about the influence of saturated
fat on important markers like heart
disease and total mortality.
I'm still waiting to hear about a study
that shows that eating more saturated,
a convincing review of meta analyses,
a meta analysis of randomized control
trials or even large observational data
that lasted for more than a short period
of time that shows that eating saturated
fat and I'm not even talking about in
the context of a healthy diet,
which is a whole other discussion,
but just in any diet increases the risk
of heart disease.
Can I stop you please?
Because we were discussing this on the
assumption that the usta had changed the
requirements for fat joel saying that's
a mistake.
I really think we should clarify that.
we should find out.
Choose my plate.gov.
It's right here.
Two thousand 15,
2020 questions about the usda
guidelines.
It said healthy diets can include up to
35 percent of calories from fat.
They put a clearcut limit on it.
It's right here.
I mean,
I'm reading it and not making it up.
But.
So usda,
it's a government.
So what was it that you remembered from
2010 and did you remember it?
Erroneously.
Let's see here.
So fucking complicated.
Oh,
it's so bad.
Yeah.
Each vegetables,
everything else follows and have some
fun.
Love your fellow man.
I have an anecdote.
Can I.
This came from a paper,
it was talking about the um,
the shift and the guidelines and I need
to,
um,
you know,
if,
why don't you tell us,
don't joel,
and we'll,
uh,
we'll get into this.
So I goTta tell ya,
I love chris kresser.
I want everybody to know that there's a
very famous food doc in santa rosa named
john mcdougal.
He's been treated people with crazy
plant based,
high complex carb diets.
He reverses diabetes.
isn't that his newsletter came out just
as I'm pulling up here and bumped into
chris.
We actually walked in exactly the same
time.
He quotes the new testament,
and I'm going to read this because as a
jewish boy,
I just got to read it.
One man.
Faith allows indeed everything.
There's some people around the table
where they would do that.
Another man's faith allows him to eat
only vegetables.
The man who eats everything must not
look down on him.
He eats only vegetables.
That man who does not eat everything
must not condemn.
The man who does.
There should be peace.
I think that is such a freaking
beautiful cats because we do need to
leave here as promoters of healthy
lifestyles,
whether we call it the harvard school
public health,
how to live 14 years longer,
the blue zones,
how to live like loma linda,
whether you want to eat game that you
hunt,
that is probably eight times less
saturated fat than what you're buying at
the damn grocery store.
You know people eat your vegetables.
People be really quality over quantity
and I'm going to tell you at some point,
let's talk about eating less and taking
some breaks for meetings so you can
activate anti aging pathways,
but um,
because you know,
it isn't all food.
It's sometimes too much.
Food is probably one of the biggest
problem for sure.
Sure.
For sure.
whether we all agree about that.
I think the real question is for someone
like me who really doesn't know.
Yeah,
I am.
I'm baffled by the saturated fat dispute
because it seems to be there's one of
you has got to be wrong here.
The evidence has got a point.
One or the other.
Chris is saying the evidence points to
be not an issue at all and you're saying
your points to being a major issue
worldwide consensus worldwide consensus,
one of these groups that rely on current
science that may or may not be behind
the times.
Oh yeah.
And I want to step back and just clarify
my position here because I'm not saying,
you know,
we started by saying there's no one size
fits all approach.
Right?
So these studies just tell us about
averages.
They tell us what happens on average
when a group of people do something,
they don't tell us actually what happens
for person a,
person b,
person c,
and that can be different.
So if you get,
like,
some people may experience a slight
increase in their cholesterol from
eating saturated fat,
some people might actually experience a
slight decrease and on a net basis that
averages out,
right?
Um,
I think the next,
the next generation of science is going
to be more of an understanding of how
various dietary components and various
foods affect people on an individual
level because let's say there's someone
who's got genetic polymorphisms that,
that mean that for that person,
if they eat a diet that's very high in
saturated fat,
their ldl particle number,
which is a risk factor for heart disease
is going to go up.
I've seen that in my clinic.
Absolutely.
I'm not saying that saturated fat will
never increased cholesterol or ldl
particle number in people.
That's just not true.
And it will,
it will,
it will happen in some cases.
Um,
but I'm just,
I'm reporting on the science,
uh,
as,
in terms of the general question of is
saturated fat going to increase the risk
of heart disease and is it going to
increase the risk of death on average
according to the available research?
And the answer to that is no.
Now,
then the next question is,
should you joe eat a very diet high in
saturated fat or should I or should
jamie,
that's a different question.
And unfortunately science is not.
we've been so focused on these
population level recommendations and the
idea that there's one diet that works
for everyone and we don't have a lot of
research that answers that question.
That's a big gap in current science.
Two questions.
One,
did you find out if you made an error on
this 2010 requirement from the usta?
So
this came from a study that's,
that reference said,
despite a lack of evidence supporting
low fat diets only in 2010,
did the dietary guidelines committee
stop recommending limits on total fat?
Um,
but I don't have the full guidelines in
front of me and,
and I,
I'm not sure what the language says so I
could have made an error.
It's possible.
Okay.
so you made it based on that,
what you just said,
that was what assumption in another
study now in terms of saturated fat
isn't there are an increased risk when
you consume fat
with refined sugars?
There absolutely is.
This is another example of where it's
at.
Mcallen is context matters.
Well,
let me just even step back a second and
say that the primary sources of
saturated fat,
and this is important to understand when
you're looking at epidemiological data,
so the sources of saturated fat in the
american diet,
33 percent comes from pizza,
desserts,
candy,
potato chips,
pasta tortillas,
burritos,
and tacos.
I'm 24 And a half percent is unaccounted
for,
but most likely processed foods
according to the authors.
And then 10 percent is almost 10 percent
sausages,
hot dogs,
bacon,
ribs and burgers.
So the vast majority of saturated,
oh,
a 13 percent is chicken and mixed
chicken dishes.
I think kfc or chicken nuggets and eggs
and mixed egg dishes,
so the vast majority of saturated fat
that americans are eating is coming from
junk,
right?
So even in an observational,
even if we did see an increase in harm
from saturated fat and observational
studies,
we still couldn't say that that would be
true for someone who's eating what I
would call like a neutral board diet,
which is,
you know,
whole foods,
fruits and vegetables,
nuts and seeds,
and some starchy plants like sweet
potatoes and animal products including
saturated fat.
We have no research that suggests that
saturated fat in that context is
harmful.
What is the mechanism that makes
saturated fat more harmful when it's
consumed with sugar?
Well,
you have a,
there is an interesting study that was
done,
um,
by,
uh,
that showed that in the context of a key
to genic diet where there's no,
no sugar essentially or very low amounts
of sugar,
that dietary saturated fat will actually
decrease blood levels of saturated fatty
acids.
And that if you're eating refined
carbohydrates,
then you,
um,
uh,
you see an increase in saturated fatty
acids that comes from,
um,
the effects of insulin essentially.
Um,
let me find you the specific.
So if you're eating a high carbohydrate
diet,
it will,
uh,
increase insulin which inhibits the
oxidation of saturated fat.
And So then when insulin levels are
high,
saturated fat tends to be stored rather
than beIng burned as fuel.
And then high carb diet can put an,
and I'm mean,
refined carbs here,
not,
um,
fruits and vegetables can promote the
synthesis of saturated fat in the liver.
So it actually causes the liver to make
more saturated fatty acids in the serum.
But this study here is a,
this showed that a controlled feeding
studies have shown that refined
carbohydrates,
I'm,
will actually increase levels of
saturated fat in the blood.
Whereas eating saturated fat in the diet
does not.
If they're,
if the diet is not high in those
carbohydrates.
Joel,
what's your take on that?
Uh,
you know,
the only key point I make to answer your
question,
chris,
is why does high sugar diets combined
with high saturated fat diet?
It's because,
again,
go back to biochemistry.
This is serious science.
we're saturated fat.
It's usually found in meat and other
animal based products.
It does exist in plants like a seminar,
avocado,
salmon,
and the olives and olive oil.
But anyways,
there's a pathway,
get insights,
but it's real stuff.
The pro,
the amino acids found in red meat out
combined with their saturated fat.
That's content triggers a pathway that
accelerates aging.
You don't want to age fast.
That's called mtor pathway,
the igf one pathway.
Then you eat a diet rich in sugar.
Well,
we know about chemistry right here in
los angeles,
university of southern California.
Bow gerontology institute.
Eat a lot of sugar.
You activate another aging pathway
called a pk ras,
and these two pathways,
mtor,
igf one,
pk rest will make you an old man or an
old woman quicker.
So when you're eating pastries,
which is high saturated fat and high
sugar,
or you're eating a meal with a coke,
how common is that?
I mean,
my god,
a hamburger and a coke,
you're activating everything we know
about science that will make you age
faster.
That sucks.
So is that true?
That eating meat and the amino acids
accelerate the aging process?
There's no studies that show that eating
meat in the context of a healthy diet
shortens your lifespan.
And if,
if so,
if that were true,
then we would see that in the data.
But joel,
you're talking about an actual physical
mechanism that accelerates the aging
processes as well known that,
you know,
what is it called again?
Well,
it's empty.
Your igf one is one pathway.
And pk rest the chemistry is not.
I mean,
this is like high level science.
It's not,
I'm not,
I'm not stretching on the limb here.
But um,
you know,
protein is really amino acids.
You know,
I get this question,
you're a vegan.
Where'd you get your protein?
My answers.
Where do you get your amino acids?
Because my body breaks protein down into
the building blocks and then I build a
backup to wherever the hell I needed for
its,
you know,
acids in meat.
There's amino acids in my head,
a mommy,
wherever I want to get them.
The the split of those 20 amino acids is
different and meat than it isn't at a
mommy.
There's more methodically and in a more
loose and very technical stuff.
Leucine,
and there were some mixes that branch
chain amino acids of lucy and I don't
know what the hell that does your aging,
but we do know that meet rich in
matthias.
Then we'll activate mtor and igf one,
and it is a very strong factor in aging.
You want a low mathiasson and diet,
so another reason,
plant based eaters,
you need to take be 12 to keep their
homocysteine to methionine and down.
That's a separate topic,
but yes,
the amino acid mixed found in animal
protein is different than the amino acid
mixed found in vegetable protein,
which is why when morgan levine looks at
the question,
what is your survival?
What's your cancer risks?
Which are heart risk on animal protein
and plant protein?
Plant protein beats the crap out of
animal Protein.
This is high level cell metabolism.
Try and publish a paper in cell
metabolism.
Beat the crap out of animal protein
because there's a 300 to 400 percent
increase in cancer of those diets
concentrating on protein of animal
source and there's a 25 percent
reduction in cardiovascular disease cell
metasys in 2014 morgan levine of
harvard.
Nobody's questioning or work october
one,
2016 song at harvard animal protein
plant protein lead to very different
outcomes in large database observational
studies at the highest level because you
can't take 6,000
people in,
randomize them in that way.
So if you're waiTing for that to resolve
the question,
you know,
good luck.
Actually not the case cd I irc panel
that confirm that concluded that that
processed meat led to an 18 percent
increase in cancer risk,
which again is like indistinguishable
from chance using that low of a relative
risk.
They.
Their conclusion was that the fresh red
meat lead was a point zero to one point
zero two.
That's a two percent increase in many
other studies have shown that
unprocessed red meat is not associated
with increase in cancer risk and is not
associated with increase in heart
disease risk.
So again,
you can talk about these proposed
mechanisms all day long,
but if it's not showing up in actual
events that are meaningful to people,
then you might be missing something.
Maybe red meat does act in certain way
that you might think would increase the
risk of death,
but maybe it does other things that
reduce the risk of death.
And that's why we can't just focus on
mechanistic studies.
We have to look at actual endpoints that
matter to people
in terms of the quality of animal
testing cancer matter.
Chris and I know you know,
said they don't know.
The studies don't show that fresh meat
increases the risk of fresh red meat
increased the risk of death and cancer
and heart disease.
Joel,
what was the number that you were
saying?
300 percent.
It's ready to anybody.
Look,
March 4th,
2014 cell metabolism.
Morgan levine,
right here.
Animal protein.
Seventy five percent increase in death.
Four hundred percent increase in cancer
over 18 year followup.
These findings were not found with plant
based protein.
So let's talk about reviews.
You're gonna reveal giants.
This is reviews our science tool.
You're saying that reviews of
observational studies and reviews of med
analyses are not science if you would
prefer to draw conclusions based on a
single study?
No,
not that I wouldn't want to a single
state,
but this is very consistent with the
overall high level of igf one.
pk,
I was
just referring to research that several
large reviews that have not found a
relationship between red,
fresh,
red meat and cancer and fresh red meat
and heart disease,
so professor to look at reviews.
That can include lots of studies and
just a single study that supports a
particular viewpoint.
Maybe.
Maybe,
maybe,
but we need more than.
Well,
okay.
The 300 percent,
what does that.
Let me let.
It's it's human study.
These are real lives.
These are real desks and these are real
cancer cases.
This is.
This is the original science and in one
of the highest level of epidemiology
where they don't take into account all
the other risk factors and then the rest
of their diet,
smoking,
sedentary lifestyle,
obesity,
all the burial.
I'll answer in a second to download the
whole paper,
but you know,
they do that.
They do multivariate
noting that there is a 2011 meta
analysis of 34 prospective studies on
red meat and colorectal cancer,
which said the event that's 34 studies,
the available epidemiologic data are not
sufficient to support an independent and
unequivocal positive association between
red meat intake and colorectal cancer.
um,
2015 meta analysis,
did find a relationship with processed
meat but did not find a relationship.
Uh,
with fresh red meat is also an issue of
dose response.
If we,
if red meat did cause cancer,
then you'd expect to see a continuous
increase in cancer rates as the intake
of red meat increased.
But in many cases you actually see the
opposite.
You can see a decrease in cancer rates
and the people who ate the most red
meat,
which cast some doubt on that
association.
Um,
and again,
we come back to the relative risks.
It like,
uh,
you know,
even with processed meat,
it's only 18 percent and you have to
consider the healthy user bias that we
talked about before.
And with fresh red meat,
it's either nothing,
zero or maybe like two percent.
And that's just like that level in
observational research is not
distinguishable from chance.
You cannot draw any concluSions on that
and you cannot assume that someone who's
eating a nutrient or diet with fresh
whole foods and is including some red
meat in that diet.
It's going to have the same response as
someone who's eating pizza,
candy hot dogs,
and all kinds of other,
uh,
junk food that's just not,
you know,
common sense will tell you.
Hence the problem with these kinds of
stuff.
Exactly.
Joel,
chris,
do you want a low igf one are.
Hi jeff.
One you want to low igf one?
You know,
just say I want to live a long,
healthy life.
I don't,
I don't want to be,
I don't want to be.
I'm obsessing over individual markers.
I want to live.
I feel like a lot of markers when it
comes to low carb steady,
she wanted a low igf one for survival.
The scientists strong.
This is la science,
so we're not making this stuff up
anyways.
My thigh and into leucine and meat
raises igf one and at least periodically
take a break.
Um,
raises insulin growth factor,
which will take your press prostate in
your breast tissue,
makes it start growing at age 50,
which is the.
Yeah,
because it's our males are for women,
for women.
Well,
just because the frequency of breast
cancer women,
it's women.
So you know,
there is a relationship
between animal products.
In breast cancer,
there's a opposite relations.
These are relationships.
There is,
there are his petri dish.
Let me just say,
go back about chemistry.
You take breast cancer cells in a petri
dish,
you put plant proteins,
they stopped growing.
You put animal proteins,
they start growing.
That's as pretty good science.
Now you say that's a petri dish.
They happen to be human breast cancer
cells,
but until you do a randomized controlled
study of animal versus vegetable,
they won't be done.
Should a breast cancer patient eat more
broccoli?
Yeah.
Let's dong the bell there again for
sure.
And I can tell you how to book cook the
broccoli so they get the best benefit.
Eat broccoli sprouts.
She kept 50 times more than
benefit that broccoli.
You were going to respond to that.
Yeah.
All right.
Come back to important endpoints,
total mortality or death from any
causes.
Um,
and diseases I'm not,
I'm not persuaded by mechanisms unless
they're tied to outcomes that we care
about.
I think mechanisms are interesting,
but as I said,
if,
if you,
you have to be aware that if foods have
multiple effects,
they might have one impact that you
might think would lead to harm,
but then they could have several other
impacts that would be beneficial and
that's why you need to look at the real
outcomes because there've been so many
examples in the past of,
of,
of ideas where the mechanism that was
originally proposed for the harm doesn't
turn out to be what we thought it was.
And so a total mortality is the most
important endpoint.
Deaths from all causes,
but then also deaths from from specific
conditions are important too.
And you and I would put that higher in
the hierarchy of evidence and
mechanisms.
Absolutely.
Joel,
I don't know how you abandoned the
unbelievable dedication and explosion of
scientists around the country and around
the world to come up with mechanisms of
disease because we're on the verge of
this unbelievable breakthrough to change
your genetics and alter your mechanism.
If you don't understand them,
you can't do it.
I think chris has it backwards more
commonly.
Basic science drives Questioning a human
population and epidemiologic study and
then maybe a randomized clinical trial
that's usual progression.
Um,
for example,
we have not even talked cholesterol.
This literally has been all saturated
fat.
Nineteen 75.
My mentors in dallas,
Texas,
but this is relevant in 2018.
Brown and goldstein basic science.
Identify your liver cell has a receptor
called the ldl receptor.
Nobody knew it.
It completely controls the metabolism of
cholesterol in the body.
They then find that there's a disease
where you don't have that receptor in
your clusters.
A thousand and you die before you're 15.
And I took care of those children in
dallas,
Texas in 1986,
1989.
From that came the development of a drug
called mevacor and lipitor and lovis.
Dad and all the rest,
and we were able to test in humans.
Does that basic science make a
difference?
Kaboom.
The forest study says you live longer.
If you have heart disease,
you need to take a step.
Yeah,
there's side effects.
Yeah.
There's this and that.
Go down to the bottom line.
You want your ldl cholesterol.
Like loren,
the founder
of the modern paleo movement said 50 to
70 and it's all consistent across
epidemiology.
Basic biochemistry,
randomized clinical studies,
and what's the average ldl cholesterol
and 100 gather in okinawa in loma linda.
Ldls are 70 or 80.
In fact,
humans are the only free living animal
on the planet with an ldl cluster over
80 [inaudible].
We eat and we gorge and we have jacked
up saturated fat that drives our cluster
up.
We're the only animal on the planet and
we're suffering terribly from policy
there does saturated fat raises.
That's the hope we need to keep coming
back to dietary cholesterol and dietary
saturated fat.
The evidence is showing that on average
they do not raise cholesterol in the
blood and even when they do that,
that doesn't translate into an increased
risk of heart disease.
That's what the data show we've talked.
I mean,
I don't know what more I can say.
Well actually we haven't.
We have a nutritionist I call bullshit
on that.
It's called the heck aesthetic equation.
In the keys equation.
I shared the data on controlled feeding
you.
You mentioned metabolic ward studies is
as a high standard of evidence
controlled feeding studies where 75
percent of people experience no change
in their blood cholesterol from eating
to four eggs a day and not exit an
isolated topic because that's a
cholesterol topic.
We have not talked cholesterol.
We've been talking saturated fat.
We talk to them about it right now.
Okay,
well,
but you just asked saturated fat and I'm
nervous.
Cholesterol,
well,
just saturated fat,
raised blood cholesterol to deny that is
is whack and I'm sorry.
That's called the aesthetic equation.
Google it.
Look it up on wikipedia.
It's called the keys equation.
That change and that change in saturated
fat raises choLesterol in the blood.
Yeah,
it does.
It's known.
It's what chris is saying that it
does.
No,
I'd say I say it does some times to some
people,
but on average the studies are saying
that it doesn't have a significant mr.
Right?
Get a large enough group of people,
you'll have some aberrations and some
people will find a significant raise.
A rising of their cholesterol.
Yeah.
And that again,
more importantly people that the
presumption here is that serum
cholesterol where we care about it
because it will increase your risk of a
heart attack,
as I said before,
large studies that have been forgotten
about cholesterol.
Just analyze the relatIonship between
saturated fat intake and heart attacks,
which is what everyone cares about,
right?
If they're thinking about cholesterol is
like the middle is,
is a,
um,
a mediator in that situation.
So they removed that and they just say,
does eating saturated fat increase your
risk of heart disease?
Not large review of 350,000
participants did not show a relationship
on average.
So is the concept that cholesterol is
just one factor and that perhaps we've
isolated it as more significant
and then it really is in our typical
reductionist paradigm.
Absolutely.
There are many factors that contribute
to heart disease and that's one of them.
Um,
and so that's why again,
it's important to look at the studies
that directly examine the relationship
between saturated fat intake and heart
disease.
Rather than doing this dance where we
go,
does it increase cholesterol?
And then assuming that high cholesterol
will lead to heart attack.
Joel,
I'm sure you can understand why this is
so confusing for me.
I,
I actually feel really badly for your
viewers and listeners.
No,
no,
they're going to be able to go over this
with a fine tooth.
This is so important.
I thank you both for doing this because
this is the kind of conversation that
you just don't get to have.
We get to experts with opposing views
and you have a decent conversation where
you go over all the actual details of it
and you get to see how each one of you
thinks about these things and how you've
drawn this conclusion.
I agree With that actually.
I think it's great and all,
but you know,
we've had a couple moments of clarity
and advice and I just want people to
have as many as possible because it does
matter wHy a friend of mine says heart
disease is not theoretical.
I mean we've had many 39 secOnd desk.
We've been doing this.
So just to respond.
I mean,
does saturated fat rich diets race
class?
I'll.
Absolutely.
It's such a tight relationship.
There's a line with a correlation that
just straight up now.
Can I pause you for a second?
Yeah.
Why?
What is wrong with these studies that
he's showing that,
that show that it doesn't in most
people?
No,
I believe,
and again there are studies that are
being referenced but we're not looking
at and that's a limitation we can live
with that since 2010 the question has
come up,
does an increase saturated fat causes
coronary heart disease?
And that has been questioned in some
studies.
The idea that it doesn't raise blood
cholesterol is a to it.
It's the reason all the guidelines up
there,
2015,
2016 still say limit saturated fat
because that science hasn't changed.
There's such a tight correlation.
The line is straight up.
Percentage of dietary fats presented
dietary saturated fat,
blood cholesterol,
the challenges,
how much yours is going to raise and how
much mine is going to raise going
depending on your genetics and your
microbiome and where you're starting.
If I ate a steak,
my cholesterol goes up.
If I ate an egg,
this has been shown because I don't eat
any dietary cholesterol is a plant
eater.
My cholesterol skyrockets.
You become habituated eating two,
three eggs a day in the curve flattens
out after two,
three eggs a day,
which is four or 500 milligrams of
cholesterol a day.
It's like if you smoke 20 cigarettes and
you go to 24,
going to be pretty hard to show.
Much of a difference to three eggs a day
for a chronic dieter is tough to
challenge your body,
just creates a tolerance for it is
there's a level of absorption that
starts to level off,
but I'm an interesting statistic.
A toothpick is 100 milligrams.
Most of us eat three to 400 milligrams
of cholesterol day three to four
toothpicks.
We're talking,
we're talking fat.
We're talking 150 grams.
So that's why the saturated fat,
it's like overwhelmingly more of a topic
than three to put three to four
toothpicks of cluster holiday.
Okay,
hold on a sec.
Because he'd just come back to the
studies.
Two to four eggs a day.
Controlled metabolic word feeding
studies do not have any impact on blood
cholesterol in 75 percent of people.
That's pretty.
That's about as conclusive as the
evidence can get.
Well and reverends.
Okay,
I'll give one to you.
I always have it.
And in they're always there at
[inaudible] dot com slash rogan.
Yeah.
No,
and here it is.
If you,
if you google kresser saturated fat,
you'll that the first article that comes
up.
So this is [inaudible],
uh,
from 2009 dietary cholesterol and
coronary artery disease.
A systemic review.
I'll just show I know your viewers.
Maybe your viewers can see it.
I don't know.
That's called saturated fat in the diet.
That's called changing your ldl.
That's called the line going up like a
straight rocket
and that will have jamie pull it up on
the big screen.
Yeah.
Anybody that googles it's called
heggstad equation egg
t e d dot.
He's from the late 19 seventies.
This was,
I know,
but the heggstad equation comes from a
heg said,
who was one of the doctors who was
involved with the mcgovern report in
1977,
which was the original report that led
to the limitation on dietary cholesterol
and saturated fat.
So,
um,
I think that's a little bit outdated
perhaps.
Like I said,
you know what joel just said though,
if metta now,
as I said,
one study doesn't,
you know,
the exception doesn't make the rule.
We have a med analysis of observational
studies including 350,000
participants that found no relationship
between saturated fat intake and
cardiovascular disease.
The review of 25 rcts and 40
observational studies,
650,000
people that concluded that replacing
saturated fat with polyunsaturated fat
doesn't lower the risk of cardiovascular
disease.
We have to look at the weight of the
evidence.
We can't just choose one study or a
mechanistic argument to support our
view.
I mean,
what's your take that this study is
flawed and out.
It's not a study that's,
uh,
that's,
he was,
uh,
an equation that was meant to represent
the relationship between saturated fat
intake and a blood cholesterol that was
created created by a in,
in the late seventies that was
originally involved in,
in this diet heart hypothesis and the
mcgovern report which led to the
restrictions on cholesterol and
saturated fat in the first place.
So yes,
I am saying that we should be looking at
more recent evidence,
large reviews of meta,
of observational studies,
then meta analyses
of randomized controlled trials.
that's,
that's the much more persuasive source
of evidence for me,
joel.
it was based on metabolic ward,
carefully done studies at harVard.
It was the equation derived from human
data and where you put people in
changing their diet,
dietary change studies drives up ldl
cholesterol ads,
plotted out complaints,
very clear.
It's changing cholesterol to dietary
saturated fat.
It's well accepted in the medical
community and it's incorporated in the
guidelines.
It'll never change.
Human physiology is not gonna change.
Ldl receptors don't change.
It all goes back to basic biochemistry
and when we understand that we can
manipulate it to better health,
we can do it through pharmacology.
we can do through diet,
will be doing it through gene therapy,
stem cell therapy,
but we don't understand about chemistry.
We're cuttIng out a pillar.
We have to have for better health.
Chris,
I don't know how many more times I feel
like I'm just saying the same thing over
and over again.
We have to look at the research,
that weight of the evidence.
We have to look at randomized controlled
trials that actually look at what
happens when people consume saturated
fat and dietary cholesterol.
These studies as the mechanistic
arguments are not persuasive.
If it's not happening in real in real
people.
You're measuring in a randomized
controlled trial.
You're controlling,
you're measuring what happens when
people eat saturated fat and
cholesterol,
and then you do a meta analysis of these
controlled trials and you're finding
what I what I just said,
that's way more persuasive to me.
What is your take on that?
Joel?
The royal academy of the same,
just the royal academy of saying,
since we can give the nobel prize in
medicine for what we're talking about
and nobody's changed that.
I mean I totally disagree with chris,
that human physiology didn't change from
1985 nobel prize to 2018,
that it's that relationship between
eating saturated fat,
lowering your ldl receptor,
raising your blood,
ldl,
developing atheroma.
I go in at three in the morning and bust
open.
Your plaques you live has not changed.
Well,
how are these studies made and what's
wrong with them?
Then the.
Nothing's changed about understanding
the biochemistry of metabolism and
cells.
Of course,
there's always advancements,
but uh,
the ldl receptor has led to the staten
field,
a new class of drugs called pcsk nine
inhibitors.
It's all because of the biochemistry
that people are living longer,
living better.
There are plaqueS are being reduced
through lifestyle medicine.
But thank god we also pharmacology
that's advanced
wrong with these studies,
these studies that are showing these
results that he's descrIbing,
that you're disputing what is wrong with
these studies and what is wrong with
their results.
Results.
Again,
I would urge everybody to take the
broad,
high level view of science and not
pixels.
What's the basic biochemistry and now
we're circling around what's the
epidemiology with the Clinical
randomized trials and what's a
centenarian studies there?
There is no new data that you live to
100 by adding saturated fat to your
diet.
You may.
We're not talking about that.
We're talking about the actual physical
results on human bodies.
When you consume saturated fat,
what he's describing,
take a new metabolic ward study that
negated
keys equation,
the state equation that there's linear
relationship.
Three hundred 95 metabolic says it
doesn't exist.
What are you saying to that,
chris?
A metabolic ward study that says eating
saturated fat.
It would not take a job where we have
randomized controlled trials which is a
very high standard of evidence and
observational data,
large amounts of observational data that
have been reviewed that answer this
question and we we also,
we have many rcts of low carb diets and
even ketogenic diets that are not
showing a significant impacts that.
Joel,
is it possible that this is,
here's a dietary,
here's a 2018 review of all of the
previous science on dietary cholesterol
in eggs,
and the conclusion says,
reese overall recent intervention
studies with eggs,
recent,
uh,
demonstrate that the additional dietary
cholesterol does not negatively affect
serum lipids,
and in some cases appears to improve
lipoprotein particle profiles like have
a beneficial effect and hdl
functionality which is the so called
good cholesterol.
And he talks about here in the
conclusion that eggs shift ldl particles
to the less detrimental large buoyant
ldl,
which is less atherogenic.
He says eggs also typically increase
hdl.
He says that eggs probably have other
beneficial impacts on in terms of their
phospho lippitt,
contact qa,
and that there's no relationship between
the consumption of eggs and heart
disease.
So thIs is a 2018 review.
It's by christopher blessed.
So dietary cholesterol,
serum lipids and heart heart disease.
Are eggs working for and against you
published in nutrients?
Joel,
is it possible that that's correct and
that there's some misunderstanding about
the previous data?
It's a different topic.
It's eggs,
it's cholesterol.
We were talking saturated fat.
Does It raise your cholesterol?
So they're different topics and then
we've introduced a very hot topic about
ldl particle size,
which we should break down and talk
about.
So I'm not sure quite how to respond
because we
got off track by shifting to
consistently low carb and the eggs and
other things.
We were talking about cholesterol,
what we're talking about
raised blood cholesterol.
So I'm,
I stand by the fact human physiology
will not change.
We have receptor understanding of human
physiology advance.
Um,
I don't.
Well,
I'll give you an example.
Until 20 years ago nobody ever heard a
word pcs canine god or somebody gave us
a protein in our blood.
Pcsk nine that goes to your Liver,
sits in a receptor,
causes the ldl receptor to go internal
and you're frigging blood cholesterol
goes up.
Now there's a class of drugs that's an
antibody to pcsk,
lowers your cholesterol draMatically,
and we're finding it reduces plaque and
lowers your risk of heart attack.
Sure.
New science.
Amazing.
Totally consistent with what brown and
goldstein showing that led to statens.
Now we have a new treatment.
That's a wonderful thing.
It didn't rock the boat a,
we still don't know to this day why we
have that a protein in our Blood and if
you're lucky enough to be born with a
low level of pcsk nine,
your cholesterol is lower,
you have less disease,
you live longer.
That was part of the data I published in
2012 with brian ferentz at wayne state
university.
So yes,
we've learned more about human
physiology.
Totally consistent,
didn't disrupt anything and lead to
better treatments.
That's great.
Um,
has,
has human physiology been challenged?
I'll give you another.
We've learned,
and chris menTioned this,
I think it's fair to go there.
It's like a court of law.
he opened it up.
I'm cross examining nobody in the world
ever heard the word of four letters.
T m a o 2011 cardiologists sitting at
the cleveland clinic said,
there's got to be more in the blood that
hurts arteries.
Let's go find him.
They found this chemical.
They learned how to measure it.
They patent and how to measure it.
Tmao.
They took 4,000
people on the cath lab table.
They said,
I wonder if the level of tmao and the
blood correlates with how clogged up
your arteries are,
but doom.
It worked perfect.
Then they figured out if you eat red
meat that has rich in l carnitine amino
acids,
you eat exits rich and coleen and a
nutrient,
I think amino acid and blanket for a
minute.
Those directly led your liver to create
tmao.
They took studies where they reduced
carnitine,
reduced coleen.
The team mail goes down.
What is tmao do it stunted your hdl so
it doesn't reverse cholesterol
transport.
It causes ldl to enter the cell wall and
create foam cells.
Macrophages,
plaque and you get a heart attack.
It actually screws up your kidney and
causes it to be fibrosis.
If you have heart failure,
diabetes,
or heart disease or hypertension,
you're tmao is up.
I've actually drawn more tmao levels.
I think any physician United States,
this is my baby.
New human physiology that has not led us
to back off the idea that limiting the
animal product consumption in this case
specifically egg yolk and red meat may
have benefit to your health.
We just learned in the academy,
increased,
went in diet,
increases tmao orders of magnitude more
hazard right in their fish flesh along
with mercury and pcbs and ddt.
What is the association of seafood
intake with heart disease mortality?
Can we use epidemiology studies or that
they're off the table?
As I said before,
we can use epidemiology when we use it
wisely,
but selective chris use it or don't use
it.
I always use epidemiology.
One hundred percent of the job.
We've been talking about large reviews
of epidemiology,
that that suggests that heart,
that saturated fat and cholesterol don't
increase the risk of heart disease.
So if you could answer Their question,
is the association of fish with
cardiova,
what would most doctors and researchers
say about fish consumption and
cardiovascular disease and mortality was
since it has saturated fat,
most high level 2018 and advisors are
two meals a week of
fish.
Balancing out with 19 meals a week of
plant based is the usda guidelines.
Answer the question long.
Can you look at the data?
There are a few things that,
that are associated with a greater
decrease in cardiovascular disease risk
than fish consumption of fruits and
vegetables.
Cmio is if you look at a graph and you
can,
if you google,
um,
let's see.
Maybe jamie,
you can pull this up.
Kresser tmao.
Um,
and you click on that first link,
red meat and tmao.
You scroll down and there's a picture of
jamie.
Where are you?
Ben?
There's a picture a scroll down.
I'm.
There you go.
So that picture shows the increase in
tmao from eggs,
beef,
cheese,
milk,
clams,
and then look at cod and halibut.
Wow.
Let me just see the reference data
reference beef,
the references in the article.
Joel,
as always,
you can see it there,
there jan referenced,
that's not fair.
Chris,
master john.
Um,
and not so cod and halibut or increasing
tmao,
as I said,
orders of magnitude more than beef or
eggs.
You can't even see eggs and beef there.
And the data show that fish consumption.
I think almost every public health
authority would recommend would agree
with this,
is reducing the risk of heart disease
and mortality.
So tmao Is another mechanism,
it's another interesting mechanism,
but not very understood.
It's not fully understood and the,
and again,
we have to look at the data on red meat
consumption and heart disease and
mortality to to really figure this out.
We can't,
you know,
it's a speculative mechanism.
I don't disagree that it's important to
look at mechanisms,
but you can't draw conclusions based on
them.
And this single fact about tmao just
kind of blows the thing apart.
The other thing about tmao to know is
that certain types of gut bacteria
metabolize coleen and carnitine into
tmao,
whereas others don't.
And so a lot of scientists have
speculated that high tmao levels are
essentially a result of a disrupted gut
microbiome.
and that makes sense.
If you have 60 percent of the calories
that americans are consuming or from
ultra processed food and we know that
that totally screws up the gut
microbiome.
Then if you get a person eating a
standard american diet,
then they're tmao.
Tmao levels may go up with red meat.
Whereas if you take someone who's got a
healthy microbiome because they're
eating lots of plant foods that support
healthy gut,
then you may not see the same
association and part of what supports
that is a.
There's studies showing that rifaximin,
which is an antibiotic
that treats bacterial overgrowth in the
small intestine,
reduces serum tmao levels,
which suggests that it's mediated by the
gut microbiome.
So consumpTion of fish has been
universally shown to decrease heart
disease.
The mechanism is interesting,
but overall it may be very complicated
with many factors and we might not know
all of them.
Yeah,
and then that's what takes us back to
let's look at the data on whether red
meat increases the risk of death or
heart disease.
Joel,
uh,
chris has referenced,
was giving credit to another bloggers
article.
That's not science.
You'd have to go to the bloggers article
and look at it was number 16.
There is.
We have to find the reference.
Sloppy referencing.
Hold on,
let him explain what the references said
there that,
that graph came.
Explain number 15 is the reference
dietary precursors of trimethylamine and
man,
a pilot study tmao.
Is that okay?
So it's not a blog.
It's actually a tmao is a hot topic
right now that is largely being
researched in terms of a egg yolk and
meat consumption.
It doesn't really matter.
It's not preliminary science.
No,
no.
It's not playing with science or coming
up with pharmacologic agents right now
to block it and we'll.
We'll see a new class of drugs they were
just reported.
Is that with significant or is it more
important to concentrate on gut biome
and healthY diet?
Well,
why?
Why are we.
Why are we instantly giving the ball to
pharmaceuticals?
You ask the question,
is there any new human physiology that's
relevant?
We've started with pcsk nine.
I'm introducing tmao is new human
physiology that's relevant that could
lead to improvements in clinical
outcomes as suggested by observation.
We're talking about what he just showed
him.
The graph.
Dismiss the graph.
Then he gave you a study for the graph
and you just sort of glossed over it,
right?
I,
I.
The one that contributed fish is a flush
source of tmao.
we can talk about whether fish in 2018
is uniformly a healthy.
I'm not saying,
and he's also talking about gut biome,
gut bacteria,
then consumption of red meat being
significantly less than the consumption
of fish,
which is universally said to be a good
thing for your heart.
A.
So a bunch of layers there.
Real quick,
everybody who studies tmao knows that
the microbiome is a critical component
to people can eat a steak.
It's classic study.
Cleveland clinic study feed a vegan
estate.
This is a classic cleveland clinic
research study in the new england
journal of medicine.
I don't make tmao why?
Because my microbiome was different than
yours feed and on the board of steak,
they make tmao within 12 hours now
eating a standard american diet.
Sure.
But none the less,
it's pointed to the fact that it was the
microbiome you give a mouse meat and
given an antibiotic that wipes out of
microbiome a won't make tmao tmao
dependency.
The microbiome dependency of tmao is
well known science.
Um,
so that,
that is not denigrate the topic.
I mean,
it's a side topic.
Is fish always healthy in a world of
ddt?
pcb mercury.
I don't know about christmas practice,
but every patient I see gets blood
mercury levels and those that eat
routinely heavy or very often,
but that's another subject.
That's another subject,
but no,
you don't want to.
You want to look at old data on fish and
now I'm bringing up 2018 clinical.
That's not what he's doing.
We're not bringing up old data on female
beat up old data and I'm bringing
relevant clinical materials about the
absolute mechanism that's caused by the
consumption of meat.
He brought up fish consumption which
vastly elevates this and yet fish
consumption is not correlated with heart
disease.
In fact,
it's correlated with people having
healthier hearts,
so if you're suggesting to me is the
recommendation today in this discussion,
eat fish,
but limit egg yolk and meet.
I'd agree with that.
That's not what it says because the fish
consumption vastly elevates what you
were saying was significant issue.
He's saying it's not a significant
issue,
that it's a mechanism and it's an
interesting mechanism,
but it's part of a much larger and
probably very poorly understood
situation.
I don't think that's completely true.
What we do know is that true?
Well,
yeah,
I would say that's true and I would say
it's another proxy marker for crappy,
crappy diet.
What we know is that eating red meat and
the context of a standard american diet,
uh,
may slightly raise your tmao but not
nearly as much as eating fish will.
So you brought up this tmao and he's
basically just squashed that argument,
but I think he's a scientifically wrong
because again,
the wealth of the body,
and I mean is that about tmao about
female because what about the fish?
Because a few specific fish,
number one,
the way that egg yolk and red meat,
cleveland clinic,
new england journal medicine is,
is this a step of eden adjusting the
precursor going through your microbiome,
going through an enzyme called
[inaudible] and your small intestine
going to your liver as tma and green
metabolize it tmao.
That process is correlated with
atherosclerosis,
atherosclerosis.
That process is correlated with
increased activity of ldl within your
cell wall,
leaded by epidemiologists,
bio chemistry,
biochemistry.
We know how it works in the petri dish.
That was the brilliance of this rapid
development from 2011 to 2013 to now,
so it's not in fish.
It hasn't been studied is if fish flesh
already has preformed tmao.
We don't know if it activates ldl
activation.
We don't know if it's dones.
Hdl.
Nobody's looked at the correlation of
fish flesh,
preformed tmao,
and a 4,000
patients studied in the cath lab table.
We don't know they're wonderful
questIons to ask,
but until they're done,
there is reason to be concerned that
there's a new pathway that might be
involved in athletes talking about a
totally different thing.
Yeah,
exactly.
If if consuming food that raises your
tmao increased the risk of heart disease
and you'd see people who are eating the
most fish,
having the most heart attacks,
and that's the opposite of what you see
that that's.
I think that's reductionist because what
does fish out reductiveness to bring up
tmao in the first place because you
brought her even more than what I just
said because I zoomed out a little bit
to look at the actual relationship with
mortality.
Well,
that was a blood level.
That's not atherosclerosis,
that's not outcome.
That's not kidney function.
That's not stroke risk and heart rates,
which happens about tmao.
I am talking about what that graph
showed was tmao back it up.
You eat red meat,
you make tmao.
If your microbiome is of a certain
constitution,
you eat egg yolk,
you make tmao.
If that's a certain constitution,
is it good to have high levels with tmao
and the blood,
whether they're from fish,
egg yolk,
or red meat?
The science of justice.
Not good.
What can you do to lower your
[inaudible]?
Let me pause you.
How does the science suggests it's no
good.
If there's large levels of tmao that
come from fish and when you eat that
fish,
it's directly correlated with less heart
disease.
What it would take an evaluation.
What's the calorie content of the United
States from cod,
halibut,
red meat and egg yolk.
I would think the calorie content of egg
yolk and red meat is higher than cotton
helmet.
I don't have that data and that's a
global perspective,
but if you are up to date in the
scientists,
say,
I'd like to lead a lower tmao life,
which again,
I'm going to say with all boldness,
I've drawn more blood levels on anybody
in the United States.
I believe according to the cleveland
heart labs,
you will want to do all steps to lower
it and maybe you want to leave fishing
because the complimentary benefit that
fishes shown maybe from omega three
speculative though we don't understand
what you're talking about.
Tmi te,
te reo as a mechanism,
right?
It's purely speculative to say that the
tmao from fish is healthy,
but the tmao from beef and eggs is not.
No,
I don't think it's have.
I don't think we know the answer because
it's seven year old science,
but you're stating it though.
Now I'm not saying that you're studying
the tmao is a massive concern.
That is scientifically true.
How is it scientifically true?
If there's so much tmao and fish and
there's no concern?
There's two species of fish that have
the highest levels.
You saw the other levels or whatever.
They're the ones filling fish in
general.
This isn't rare fish and we're not,
we're not talking about higher.
We're talking about beef and eggs barely
even register on that grass.
Orders of magnitude higher.
Like what percentage looked like 20
times.
It was hiding.
Yeah,
I probably 20 fold higher.
Twenty four,
20 times higher.
Like I might've even mentioned that in
my,
in my original article.
joel,
the problem is you brought up to mayo in
the first place.
Like it was this.
Well,
but let me just tell you,
okay,
let's,
let's everybody look at molecular
nutrition food research.
2016.
Does fish protein when it elevates tmao
accelerated atherosclerosis according to
a research study,
when fish raised tml,
they accelerate atherosclerosis.
Anybody can check the lead author.
I cannot
say the name yazdi gosh,
dee.
Conclusion reached,
um,
a,
a petri dish.
Data,
uh,
is a petri dish.
I'm looking for a minute.
It's basic biochemistry.
What happens to atherosclerosis in
arteries when you feed this was a mouse
data.
That's how you generate hypotheses.
Well,
it hasn't been done in humans yet.
It's not such a thing as pure fact.
Well,
the assumption is the fishes a
superfood.
I've Already knocked It down for several
reasons.
One,
the fish intake is associated with
increased risk of diabetes.
I'm sorry,
that's epidemiology.
Fish is here with inCreased risk of
diabetes.
Yes,
it's got protein epidemiology studies.
So the question is,
is there a randomized study,
basic biochemistry.
You would understand that from the
saturated fat content of fish.
It would be largely epidemiologic
studies,
things like that,
but when you're saying epidemiology
studies,
you're asking people what do you eat on
a regular basis and if they say fish and
french fries and hot dogs,
right?
You say,
oh,
the fish is associated with an increase.
That's where it can happen and it's not
isolated.
It's connected.
All the other things with that isolated
what you're trying to isolate out things
by multivariate analysis.
Emmy is not one study,
it's many,
but diabetes and Fish really is that
real?
It's real.
It's
review that said that and review because
there's a 2012 review that does not find
any association between fish consumption
and diabetes.
So you're thinking this is for 440,000
people with an average of 11 year follow
up published in the american diabetes
association,
diabetes care journal.
So I.
Yeah,
I don't think you know it.
It's,
it's hard I think to make the claim that
fish consumption is harmful for the
enormous weight of evidence and yes,
there are concerns now about toxins then
it might change over time and there are
also issues with overfishing and all of
that,
but on different story we're talking
about just the association of fish
consumption and health and longevity.
And I think if you've got 100 scientists
in the room,
maybe 99 of them would agree that that's
a,
that you know,
there are a few things in nutritional
research that are less controversial
than that.
Well maybe,
I mean I'm just,
I'm not making this shit up.
Journal,
american college and nutrition intake of
fish was correlated positively with the
increased risk of diabetes.
I mean the science is out there.
Is it crystal clear as well defined as
the head of state equation,
dietary saturated fat changing
cholesterol?
No.
Is it an association that could be of
concern and basic biochemistry said,
fish?
You have saturated fat that could
possibly caused something called lipo
toxicity fish.
You have animal protein.
We've already talked where animal
proteins very different than plant
proteins.
The concept is plausible.
Sure.
Is it resolved?
It's not resolved.
Is fish a better than eating
fried chicken or a piece of affiliate
hoagie stake?
Absolutely.
It's upsetting.
Just pull it up.
Then up here it says the findings is not
supportive.
Beneficial effect of total fish type of
fish or epa and dha intake on the risk
of type two diabetes.
Alternatively,
other dietary components such as
selenium and unmeasured contaminants
present,
present in fish.
Might explain
jamie,
dude,
read the sentence.
Total fish intake was associated
positively with the risk of type two
diabetes that says there's epidemiology.
That should be further studied,
but maybe somebody wants to cut back
their fish,
but we're looking at a single study here
to look at the weight of evidence.
Jamie,
you're bad man.
A minute.
It says findings do not support a
beneficial effect of total fish type of
fish or epa dpa on the intake,
on the risk of type two diabetes like
it,
lean fish was associated with developing
type two diabetes.
Fatty fish was not because you probably
want that omega three,
but you know,
I'm not telling anybody it's a resolved
issue.
Is that yours?
Sang tma from animal protein is what
causes this problem?
No,
it's actually more specific.
It's coleen and carnitine in egg yolk.
It's not really animal protein.
That's.
But you said the tmao tmao.
Tmao is.
Okay,
so what's in meat?
That's not good for you.
although if you're hungry on an island
and you're dying,
eat meat,
we all recognize it,
but if you're looking for optimal
health,
you should be concerned about saturated
fat content.
You should be concerned that animal
protein accelerates aging and igf one is
it,
but proven that animal protein
accelerates aging.
well.
if he says no,
we should just stop because that's it's
world class science.
I mean,
just because you say it doesn't mean we
did go visit a possibility that high
intakes of mathias [inaudible],
which isn't one of the amino acids in
animal protein in the absence of
sufficient intakes of glycine,
which is another amino acid that's in
animal proteins and an intake of
nutrients like b,
12 and b,
six and b,
nine,
which is full eight.
Could some of the animal studies suggest
that that has an effect on longevity,
but this is why I've always been an
advocate of eating nose to tail,
so not just eating lean meats that are
very high and matthias and making sure
you're getting enough of the glycine
rich foods,
the bone broth,
et cetera,
and then you're also eating plenty of,
you know,
a mixed diet that contains 12 and full
eight and b six and the other nutrients
that balance out the effects of excess.
MatthIas matheny as well as fiber for a
healthy gut.
Absolutely.
And when you pulled up that conclusion,
no fiber in meat,
no meat,
yeah.
Will you eat other things?
I've never argued.
I've never bad except Sean Baker.
Well,
there's a whole nother ball of wax or
that whole carnivore diet conclusions at
accumulated evidence generated from this
meta analysis does not support the
overall inverse association of fish or
fish oil intake with incidents of
diabetes.
That'S saying that they couldn't confirm
increase fish intake doesn't lower the
risk of diabetes.
It's not saying that it increases the
risk.
So it says it's not a,
there's no relationship there taking
place.
So it's not that no one's saying that it
causes diabetes.
So whatever it does.
When,
when,
uh,
where,
where does it say that it causes
diabetes?
What does this study nobody said to.
Cause this is classic association
because you don't know if it's the
protein,
the fat,
the mercury,
the pcbs and ddt.
The people that are fish die.
Yeah.
They're eating fish and chips.
Tv.
Absolutely.
This is clearly not to the level of
saying processed red meat causes cancer.
This is saying fish consumption in some
studies is associated with type two
diabetes.
These are heavily flood studies.
Would you agree?
I wouldn't throw them all under the bus.
You know,
that's how science works.
I mean,
it slowly plods forward,
smiling.
Yeah,
I mean we,
we were starting,
joe brought up tmao and then that's how
we got onto fish in diabetes.
I think there is no strong evidence that
fish causes diabetes.
Eating fish causes diabetes.
There's a lot of evidence that suggests
that eating seafood reduces
significantly the,
the incidence of cardiovascular disease.
And again,
if tma out were a problem then eating a
lot of fish,
it should not have that impact.
I believe that this is probably.
Well I shouldn't say you believe.
Do you believe this is from essential
fatty acids that are found in fish,
particularly fatty fish?
Yeah.
I think that's plausible given what we
know about epa and dha,
which are the long chain essential fatty
acids and their benefits and it could be
fish is also a really great source of
selenium as,
as that one study said 16 and the tWenty
five top sources of slain income from
ocean fish.
Fish is a great source of bioavailable
protein.
Um,
there are lots of reasons why,
why fish consumption could be
beneficial.
So
in your opinion,
tHis sort of highlights that there's a
lot of complex different moving parts
that we dOn't totally understand and
that this is why you don't want to rely
completely on just the mechanisms and
these things that are occurring in petri
dishes or mice studies or
things along those lines.
Yeah.
So going back to the bradford hill
criteria that we mentioned before,
which are ways of kind of determining
whether associations that should show up
and observational studies might be
causal.
The plausibility one of one of the
criteria is mechanism.
Is there a plausible
mechanism that could explain the
relationship between this variable and
that variable?
But there are other criteria,
strength,
consistency,
specificity,
temporality,
plot,
a biological gradient like a dose
response.
Um,
coherence experiment analogy.
So yes,
mechanisms are great.
We,
it's important to study them.
I'm all for that and we,
we absolutely need to correlate them
with real outcomes and real human beings
to see both in observational studies
that are well designed and in randomized
controlled trials to see if it makes
sense.
And the tmao.
I think it's a great example of that.
Does it,
is it fair to say that we really just
are looking at a puzzle and we don't
have all the pieces?
I think you can say that in many cases
and in this case for sure.
Yeah.
I disagree that there's a tremendous
group and you can pull this up.
If we went jamie called true health
initiative,
it's more than 400,
I'd call world experts on nutrition
fairy divergent food philosophies,
paleo mediterranean plants specifically
disagreeing well so that there's no
consensus to advise the public on a
healthy diet for humans.
They disagree.
That's what we said.
That's what we.
What we said was that there's.
It's a complex puzzle and we don't have
all the pieces.
Well,
I agree with that,
but we have enough to make
recommendations because we have enough.
We have enough to make recommendations
to the public and the true health
initiative has crystallized that.
Okay,
but that's not what we were discussing
right there about recommendations to the
public.
We were talking about mechanisms and
whether or not it's understood all the
different moving pieces in terms of how
your body absorbs nutrients and food.
It's good.
It's an endless flow of new knowledge
and that's what I said,
but why?
Why did you disagree with that?
I didn't disagree with it.
I completely agree with you.
I disagree when he said that.
That's an accurate assessment that we
don't have all the pieces to the puzzle.
We definitely go to have all the pieces.
We have enough to make recommendations
and then we'll reevaluate and all.
Do you want another new meat problem?
It's coolest.
Latest science.
Sure.
Okay.
Jamie,
will you go to please meet allergy on
google,
university of Virginia,
atherosclerosis.
So little tolerance meat allergy.
You wait and go to the second tick.
Oh,
you got a baby.
You are so good.
Joe lactose,
my gel.
I am so overwhelmed by your science and
I mean that sincerely.
You see the one that says nih?
It's a number to hit and google,
but this is something that is caused by
an adverse reaction to it.
You've got to listener here who's in
Virginia.
Maybe you see a segue question whether
the average person should eat meat
though,
but if you get started with this here,
go ahead.
So this is diabetes.
I don't know if I'd go to the second
one,
you'll have the picture just real quick.
Okay.
You live in Virginia,
you end up putting god.
You're right.
You end up,
you end up on my cath table because
you're in the emergency room for
whatever reason.
Okay.
I draw a blood sample on you.
Twenty four percent of those people have
a antibody to alpha gal,
which is a carbohydrate found in meat
and that shocks people.
There are carbohydrates and mainly red
meat specifically and only red meat,
specifically 24 percent of Virginia and
so the antibody,
so that was interesting and some are now
developing anaphylaxis,
carrying epi pens because they've
immediate allergy.
that isn't two point four percent is 24
percent have the antibody,
but what was discovered university of
Virginia is if you then look at their
heart arteries by ultrasound,
the more plaque they have,
the higher is there.
Tighter the antibody brand new science.
It's an association.
Nobody knows there is of course the
possibility of inflammation from immune
activation.
That's wild data.
Now,
I don't wish that on people.
I wished we live in a world,
but people didn't have nut allergies,
didn't have lactose in towns and didn't
have meat allergies,
but the reality is there may be a
pathway previous unknown that is hot,
and this all goes back to your question.
Is there any new physiology about this
whole stop you right there.
This is a pathogen activated allergy
that's from a pretty severe.
People don't walk around with this
without knowing that they have it.
They have severe allergic reactions.
It's basically like lyme disease,
that lactic.
We're not talking about like a mild gi
discomfort when we're talking about us.
I don't think this is a mechanism that
has existed for a long time to explain
anything,
but this is something that's only been
discovered over the last couple of
decades.
Of those 24 percent that have the
antibody,
very few had the full clinical syndrome,
but it's still correlated with heart
disease.
The point is,
keep an open mind.
I don't see the data accumulate and
getting healthier.
can I ask you this?
Do you think that it's because they have
a mild case of this tick borne disease
or this tickborne disease is like
because it is fairly recent in terms of
our discovery of it,
is it advancing and evOlving and getting
more potent?
I doubt you know,
the basic biochemistry of meat and the
carbohydrates and meet have changed.
It has the.
Has the lone star tick become more
frequent naps,
cross reaction between glyphosate and
being bit by a tick and our intestinal
permeability.
There's all kinds of crazy ideas that
need to be pursued because some of them
will run santos round off.
It's fair.
It's,
it's all their correlation is not
causation.
we know you agree with this job.
We didn't have to keep that in mind.
I mean it's that there's a great study
done in one of my favorites.
It was purposely done to illustrate the
danger of assuming that correlation
equals causation.
It was a study done of the most common
diagnoses for hospitalization in Canada.
10 point 6 million people and they found
that 24 diagnoses were significantly
associated with the participants
astrological science,
so people
who are born under the sign of leo had a
15 percent higher risk of being
hospitalized for gi,
gastrointestinal hemorrhage,
and sagittarians had a 38 percent higher
risk of being hospitalized for an arm
fracture.
Now remember the the candidates,
the proposed increase in risk of for for
process meat and cancer is 18 percent,
so these risks are on the process at the
same process,
meet at that same level so it
sagittarian has a higher risk of being.
If we believe in this correlation data,
you know you can't assume correlations
or causation.
I mean that's basic and I,
and it doesn't again,
there extent you can use bradford hill
and other things to strengthen the
association,
but you need to test it with an
experiment or the association needs to
be strong.
It needs to be over 100 percent at least
to really rise out of the noise and then
say,
okay,
we're really seeing a signal.
Let me give you another example.
There was a recent study just published
that showed that women pregnant women
with the highest maternal consumption of
gluten had a twofold risk of type one
diabetes and their offspring and their
children.
That was a double,
that was over a hundred percent.
So that is actuallY worth paying
attention to because that's so such a
large increase in risk that it doesn't
confirm it by any stretch.
But it does mean.
Yeah,
maybe we should look into this further.
If that was a five percent increased
risk,
I mean,
you,
you might as well say that sagittarians
have a higher risk of fracture.
Is it fair to say that we're doing all
these nutritional studies that you're
looking at a poverty of data?
Yeah,
I'm johnny.
Johnny enedis had a quote.
Uh,
let's see if I can quickly find it.
Um,
because we're comparing all these
different studies and mean obviously
joel thinks one thing.
You think another thing.
So,
so here's the,
here's the end of this quote.
Moreover,
given the complicated associations of
eating behaviors and patterns,
uh,
oops,
lost my place.
Given the complicated associations of
eating behaviors and patterns with many
time varying social and behavioral
factors that also affect health.
No,
currently available cohort includes
sufficient information to address
confounding in nutritional association.
So he's saying,
you know,
lay-person translation,
there's so many factors that affect our
health from our sleep to our physical
activity to our,
uh,
whether we smoke,
whether we drink your,
our social relationships.
There was a study that I think I talked
about,
um,
one of my previous appearances that,
that shows that I'm having not having
enough good relationships will increase
your risk of death more than smoking 15
cigarettes a day,
no studies or controlling for that gut
microbiome we now know is really
important for our overall health.
Are any sTudies comparing for pe?
You know,
actually controlling for people's state
of people's got microbiome?
Absolutely not.
Which is a problem with the tmao
research.
So again,
it doesn't mean that observational
studies are not useful.
It means we have to take them with a
huge grain of salt and the fewer things
that are actually controlled for the
bigger,
the grain of salt will be joe w.
I eman,
I kind of had a sense that it's so
overwhelming and there's so many spots
in the data that we're unable to advise
the public.
Again,
I don't agree with that.
I Think we have more than enough data.
you can go to michael polan,
eat food,
not too much.
Mostly plants.
Everybody loves it because it's
consistent with the overwhelming 50,000
level.
Look,
you can go to the true health initiative
that says 15,000
level look.
Yeah,
no.
The whole level of biology,
basic science,
centenarian,
randomized clinical trials,
epidemiology.
You got to talk to a patient monday
morning.
I don't want to get mired in confusion.
I'm going to tell that patient eat real
food.
Don't eat too much and eat mostly plants
because that is a synthesis of 50 years
in nutritional research.
are we going to evolve that to something
more brilliant?
You might add now fast five days a month
or don't eat 12 hours a day.
We might be able to refine it with some
of the new science on it using fasting
intelligently,
but that's pretty strong.
When I go to the true health initiative
and say it's all confusing,
but 400 scientific international experts
say,
eat locally,
source close to the ground per plant
predominant with water.
400 scientists say that's pretty
reasonable,
that I can tell my patient on monday is
something they can actually activate and
we'll figure out tmao with a blocker
with fish or with eggs with coleen or
whether this tick allergy ends up
spreading into Michigan or California.
And There's a way to deal with it.
For now.
These are critically simple lessons for
the public.
I'd actually agree with that.
Including the part about plants.
I mean,
I recommend my recommendation is your
plate should be,
you know,
two thirds or three quarters plants and,
and then,
and then animal products,
animal foods.
So the question here is not that,
should we eat a healthy whole foods
diet?
We both agree on that 100 percent.
The question is whether animal foods,
uh,
should be a part of the diet based on
their nutrient density,
which unfortunately we haven't had a
chance to get into yet.
And their bioavailability and the fact
that humans in our hominid ancestors
have been consuming them for over two
and a half million years.
Um,
you know,
that's my argument is that,
uh,
on that plate,
for most people,
they're going to benefit from having
some animal foods.
How much,
you know,
what proportions of carbohydrate,
fat,
protein,
and all of that.
That depends on the person and you're
going to see big differences actually
from person to person.
Um,
but you know,
I,
I think today has made it clear there's
no convincing data that shows that
completely removing animal products from
that plate going to lead to a longer
life span or significant reductions in
disease.
Let me put it this way.
What is the benefit of putting that one
quarter of your plate putting animal
protein?
Like what,
what Is the nutrient density of it that
makes lots of benefits?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
animal protein is,
um,
more nutrient dense in essential
nutrients.
So,
so making it clear that I,
I,
I support eating both plants and animal
foods.
So animals or animal foods are higher
and be 12 bioavailable zinc,
iron,
calcium,
a coleen taurine,
creatine,
and not just higher in terms of the
actual amounts but higher in the amount
that you,
that you absorb.
And that's a very key point.
whereas plant foods tend to be higher in
carotinoids polyphenols,
flavanoids,
diallo,
little sulfides which are in cruciferous
vegetables and fiber and those are
important as well.
And so to get the best of,
you know,
the,
the widest spectrum of nutrient density,
we want to eat the animals for those
nutrients in animal foods and then the
plant foods for those other nutrients.
And whaT would be negative about
removing the animal products from that
one quarter of your plate?
What,
what could you not fill in with plant
protein a,
b?
Clearly some people get by with just
plant protein b.
12 is the,
is the biggest issue for sure.
Um,
it's not really found in plant foods
except for some exotic species of wild
mushrooms and,
and nori and plants and mushrooms aren't
really plants.
Right?
But yeah,
in non animal foods,
yeah,
I guess you could say,
um,
but if it's not just a question of
what's theoretically possible,
it's a question of looking at the
studies that show us what are the
average,
uh,
you know,
how common are nutrient deficiencies on
omnivorous versus vegetarian and vegan
diets.
And if you go to [inaudible] dot com
slash rogan,
there's a whole section on that that
links to a very in depth article that
shows that,
for example,
of vegetarians and vegans,
the average omnivore,
the rate of between depletion is 11
percent.
And then for vegetarians at 77 Percent
and for vegans it's 92 percent,
92 percent of depletion,
which is the first stage.
There's four stages of b,
12 deficiency.
And that's the first stage.
And the earlier studies that showed less
of a difference used only crm b12 as a
marker,
but it turns out that crmb 12 is not a
very accurate marker of b 12 deficiency.
And we need to be using more accurate
markers like holo,
transcobalamin,
methylmalonic acid,
homocysteine.
And when you use those newer markers,
you see those broad,
broad,
you know,
very big differences,
deficiency rates and furthermore there
was a study done in vegans and
vegetarians in the Netherlands that were
at a summer camp.
So these were people who were educated
vegetarians and vegans,
they were really into it and the average
crmb 12 level for them even it was below
200,
which is in a deficiency state.
And even the people who were
supplementing had significant levels of
b 12 deficiency.
And that's probably because studies have
shown that the amount that you need to
supplement with is about a 100 times
higher than the rda.
So the rda is two point five micro grams
and you really need 250 micrograms to
get your levels up.
And if you're deficient you need 200
times more than the rda,
500 micrograms and this.
All the studies are there on,
on my site.
So it is the problem that beat twelves
nonexistent and plant based foods or
that it's not as bioavailable.
It's,
it doesn't exist.
The true,
true cobalamin absorbable b12 doesn't
exist in implant that you can't,
um,
you can get other koba minds,
other forms of implant,
even algae,
even algae.
Yeah.
Most,
most vegans who are well who were
educated about this know this and they
take a 12 suPplement.
So,
but the [inaudible] supplement is
probably based on what,
like what is it coming from?
Well,
it's not that,
that,
that doesn't necessarily make the
difference.
It's are they taking enough to meet your
needs?
So I hope that anyone who is listening
to this make sure that they're getting
enough b,
12,
you know.
RIght.
But what is it coming from?
If it's not active?
I make be 12 cows are eating dirty
ground.
they get bacteria,
cows stored in their stomach plants if
you don't wash will give you be 12.
But it's the bacteria hanging on the
carrot
and we make the 12 too,
but It's in the colon and we can absorb
it in the small intestine.
Right.
So,
um,
but yeah,
just making sure that if someone is
following this diet,
they're getting enough b 12 and that
they're using the right markers to
assess their status.
Crmb 12 only goes out of range In the
final stages of b 12 deficiency and by
then it can be too late some of the
effects of b 12 deficiency or
irreversible.
So it's a pretty serious thing and it's,
it's a really important thing for any
vegetarian or vegan to be aware of,
given those big differences in
depletion,
uh,
between the population.
So joel,
if you been a vegan since you've been
18,
obviously must've been on top of all the
supplementation and making sure that you
get your nutrients
well,
it's out.
Number one,
it's responsible for a healthcare
practitioner to advise somebody eating
plant based to take vitamin b.
12.
Absolutely.
There are people that do it because it's
fortified in many foods and nori,
if you eat sushi and nutritional yeast,
I don't advise my patients to rely on
food because there's a neurologic and
hematologic potential for trouble.
If you don't be 12,
it actually takes years to deplete your
b 12.
It's an interesting statistic.
I want to come back to humans.
Ninety percent of all b,
12 right now is being given to lock cows
because they don't eat dirt anymore.
They're inside a building that has no
dirt.
They dOn't get be 12,
but the public wants be 12 rich meat,
so they'd give be 12 to cows to make b
12.
There is little vegans.
These cows,
they don't have a source anymore.
No animal.
They usually talking about factory
farming,
factory farming.
You know if you're out there eating dirt
in the field are going to have a
college,
have a job,
be right here.
When you say that,
so is it impossible to live a healthy
plant based lifestyle without
supplementation?
No.
Many many people do,
but if you're saying you don't remember
amended,
I don't recommend it,
but they should get bloodwork.
Know your vitamin d,
no,
your omega three and know your b 12.
I'm all for optimal health and I'm
practicing high level medicine,
but I have friends that adamantly show
me their blood work.
I don't take pills and look at my blood
work.
I mean they may sneak by.
It's not my medical recommendation.
The fish and recommendations is every,
everybody over age 50 and the United
States take be 12 for brain and mental
health,
whatever your diet and that's a wise
advice.
Whether you take a multivitamin every
couple of days like dr longo recommends
there's,
you know,
this is a real problem.
Nobody's denying that chris has laid it
out.
Well,
it's such a simple solution.
I'm going to demonstrate my be 12.
What's the source of your [inaudible]?
It's synthesize methological bombing.
I just got 1000 micrograms of vitamin b,
12 with 400 micro with 400 milligrams of
dha with 2000 international units of
vitamin d three and I did vegan.
I just did that once a day and I'm done.
You know,
and it's all vegan and has nothing to do
with living organisms.
It's made synthesized a,
b.
Twelve is synthesizing labs.
MethylcobAlamin,
some people believe is the preferred
choice,
which I think chris would agree with.
Contrary to popular belief,
it can be gotten by completely humane
and ethical ways.
If you're a,
oh,
it's lpg,
it's lg for dha,
it's synthesize for be tWelve and
vitamin d three is synthesized to it
used to be made from cows,
a secretion called land,
a sheep's secretion
called land limpets synthesize now,
but it does beg the question of whether
we should be following a diet that can't
meet our essential nutrient needs and
that leads to deficiencies of many other
nutrients much more commonly than an
omnivorous diet.
And you know,
my,
my position has always been we should
get as many nutrients as food as we as
we can because that's the way that
humans are adapted to getting new
nutrients.
There's issues with supplementation
sometimes.
Um,
you know,
both like getting too much of a nutrient
is,
can be a problem in several cases.
That's not the case in b12,
which is great because it means people
can take really high doses and it won't
be a problem.
But as I mentioned,
a lot of vegetarians and vegans who are
supplementing are still at risk and
still deficient because crmb b 12 is the
main marker that is used in this
country.
And not even,
most physicians don't test for cmv
tWelve.
I know this,
you probably know this,
joel from people come in,
they've never had be 12 tests,
but then when they do get the cnb 12
tests,
it's going to miss a large percentage of
people who are already in the stage two.
I do a methylmalonic methylmalonic.
Yeah.
So methylmalonic acid and homocysteine
are much more important markers and I
agree.
If you look at average homocysteine
levels in vegans and vegetarians are
significantly higher than in omnivores
because of this issue,
because of the high prevalence of,
of b12 deficiency.
And what's ironic about that is a lot of
people turn to a plant based,
I don't even want to say plant based
because I would consider a neutral or a
paleo diet to be plant based to but uh,
no animal product diet to improve their
cardiovascular health.
And yet you're seeing much higher rates.
Your rates of homocysteine,
like the average and vegans is 16,
which is a rate that's clearly
associated with increased risk of not
only cardiovascular disease,
but also dementia and alzheimer's.
RighT.
Chris?
I couldn't agree more.
I've written many articles,
don't be a dumb vegan and I don't mean
to offend,
but you know what you know you,
you,
we are prone and I mean there's no
bullshit here.
This is too important for people.
We are prone to have a few holes in the
wall that an intelligent person knows
how to plug it.
Vitamin d,
it's dha,
it's be 12.
You might go onto say iodine touring
vanadium,
chromium.
I just got those.
That's what I do every other day.
I'm totally complete.
My patients are totally complete.
The industry has provided solutions to a
relatively simple problem.
I don't.
So you got a mouthful.
Let me ask you questions.
Is,
is it fair to say that you believe that
What the vegan diet is like?
You can essentially hack your way to a
better,
healthier life by just adding a few
things like be 12,
a few other nutrients that you're not
going to get from the diet,
but with those together you feel like
you're far healthier.
Well,
because what I didn't get,
I substituted,
but what I don't want,
I'm not taking in,
which is animal saturated fat animal
protein.
I'm not taking
main disagreement here between the two
of you is whether or not saturated fat.
Chris and I would both agree as
educators,
all the public and specifically plant
eaters should be aware of nutritional
deficiencies.
A two year paleo followup study said
that people were deficient in iodine on
the paleo diet.
Sounds have much higher rates of iodine,
but you know it's common in America.
MucH higher
rates of iodine deficiency than paleo
unless you eat some nori,
some kelp,
unless use iodized salt.
If you would just put
though that the paleo diet is the issue,
just people deficiency.
Paleo diet goes back 10 to 12 years in
literature.
Two thousand nine is about the first
good paleo.
Sansa showed up and I honor the paleo
diet.
There is good reason to consider it as a
food option.
They'll us news and world report does
not agree with that,
but to say,
what are they basing it on?
They're not scientists.
Well,
their panel of scientists that they read
it,
they read it for lunch.
The bigger question is just what?
You know what's going to happen for the
average person who's following these
diets and I agree 100 percent with joel
that you know,
we have to educate people on whatever
diet they're on and I've,
I've,
I've said this to people,
that's why I'm not,
I've never advocated strict paleo be.
I mean I think that can work for some
people,
but I've never been an ideological about
that because I actually think that full
fat fermented dairy is really beneficial
when it's well tolerated and one of the
reasons for it is iodine dairy is
actually one of the best sources of
iodine in the diet and it's not because
the dairy products contain iodine but
they're stored in tanks that were iota
for is the cleanser that's used for the
tanks.
We basically pure just pure it.
Interesting and,
and gross.
It's not,
it's just,
it's like,
you know,
the iodine you use to clean.
It's just a natural nutrient.
Where do you get it from food though
outside?
So the three top sources of iodine would
be.
Well iodized salt is the main one.
That's why it was added to salt in the
first place,
but a lot of people on a healthy diet
remove iodized salt in favor of sea
salt,
which I think is a good choice overall,
but one of the downsides of that is that
there are no longer consuming the main
source of iodine.
Then dairy products and then sea
vegetables,
as joel mentioned,
I'm like kelp and he jiechi and rma and,
and no worry,
not as much,
which is the only sea vegetable that
most americans consume in the form of
sushi.
Right?
Um,
so if you take someone on a,
on a vegan diet or a paleo diet for that
matter,
and they remove dairy seat,
a iodized salt and they're not eating
sea vegetables,
then yes,
that is a risk for iodine deficiency.
I have written about that,
but let's look at things like calcium.
Let's look at iron.
Let's look at zinc.
Let's look at coleen.
Let's look at taurine.
Let's look at creotine.
Let's look at retina,
which is preformed vitamin a.
And let's look at epa and dha.
All of these are shown to be lower in
vegetarians and vegans and they are in
omnivores and it Just,
yes,
you can supplement,
but it just,
you know,
are the supplements have the same
effect,
like look at calcium.
dietary calcium has inversely related to
heart disease and kidney stones,
meaning the more dietary calcium you
eat,
the lower risk of those conditions.
But when you look at studies on calcium
supplements,
the opposite is true calcium supplements
are associated with an increase in heart
disease and an increase in kidney
stones.
So associated by epidemiology studies.
Yes,
yes.
So,
but the theory is that because you went
with the supplemental,
calcium is not the same as dietary
calcium.
You get a large bolus of calcium that
goes into your blood all at once and
then it can get into the soft tissues
which you know,
can make them stiffer,
which is joel will tell you is not good
for your heart health.
And so my point is that supplements
don't always affect the body in the same
way.
That's why I just think it's better to
get nutrients from food if you can,
because that's the way we've been
getting them for
millions of years,
you know,
let's talk about something I think you
guys can both agree on because I am
baffled by this carnivore diet.
Yes.
And baffled.
I'm baffled by how many people are
clinging to it as a panacea.
I'm baffled by whether or not it's a
physiological effect or whether there's
a placebo effect going on.
I have a theory please.
Yeah.
So my theory is that it mimics some of
the benefits of fasting,
but allows people to persist for longer
because it's providing some nutrition.
You know,
most,
if you look in the scientific
literature,
fasting is the cure.
all for everything I agree with.
you mean like you can look at any
condition and fasting is the cure time,
water fasting.
So you can do it for two,
three,
four weeks.
I tried that for a year and that will be
the cure for life in that case.
The longest example is a year of water
fest.
So most people die.
That last,
uh,
it was,
he was extremely obese,
a lot of energy stores,
fat stores,
right.
Anything about that was he actually his
skin shrank to.
Right.
Which is really,
yeah.
Which doesn't usually happen with weight
loss,
so this is just a theory.
I have nothing to,
you know,
I don't have any evidence,
but we meet as absorbed very high up in
the digestive tract.
And so when you only eat meat,
it's a low residue diet and there's
nothing leftover to irritate or inflame
the gut.
My theory is a lot of people who are
benefiting from this have a really
disrupted gut microbiome.
Alessio fasano has argued that leaky gut
is kind of a preconditioned for auto
immunity and this,
the carnivore diet is essentially like a
gut rest or a fast.
And so I don't know the out that people
are benefiting from it.
The question is what is the longterm
implication?
But there is no.
I mean there's a few people that have
been doing this,
some anecdotal evidence.
We've been doing it for a few decades.
Well,
you know,
it's pretty cool.
I'm actually going on my homeboy sean
baker's podcasts in a few weeks.
We're humble.
We started.
Sean and I started as enemies.
We love each other.
Shannon,
I love your brother.
We're going to have an honest discussion
as much as you can to say why has my
Kayla Peterson feeling good and you got
to love that and honor that.
If she had done water fasting,
transitioning to an ultra clean diet,
which you have done as well,
who knows,
but to look at sean baker's labs and say
prediabetic low testosterone high bun.
I'm concerned,
although he just published his coronary
calcium scan to zero and I honor that
he's got little kids.
I don't want the guy to drop dead,
but you know,
there's it's way preliminary for the
bandwagon.
That's testosterone thing though is he
said that he had been dead lifting the
day before and the day before he took
his test out of sydney.
Significantly decreased testosterone.
Well,
he said he repeated it a few times and
has stayed low,
but if you're total raised,
it didn't raise rates by 100 percent.
No,
it was.
It was like 237,
I can't memorize last,
but there's little
though.
There's plenty of data.
If you're sharing a total testosterone
was less than 250.
It's an adverse mortality predictor and
you know,
he wants to be alive.
He doesn't need to do it.
Kayla peterson and Jordan might need to
do it until they find a better path.
Sean's,
you know,
uh,
adopted it.
So there's,
you know,
the biggest puzzle is quickly,
quickly,
one of the things that plant based
eaters and people that fill three
quarters of their plate with fruit and
vegetables get way more than everybody
else has lots of vitamin c and vitamin c
builds healthy walls and build south
immune systems.
You love vitamin c?
I love vitamin c,
I love it from foods.
I don't mind it as a supplement.
I don't mind it.
Intravenous vitamin c,
linus pauling.
There's so many,
uh,
benefits of the body.
Where are these people?
When every chart says that meat has no
vitamin c,
are they eating raw meat?
Which might've vitamin c?
Are they eating organ meat which might
have some invited?
Let me stop you there because I'll tell
you what the explanation has been.
The explanation to me has been that
there is a decrease in absorption of
vitamin c when you're consuming vitamin
c with all these other things.
Cruciferous vegetables,
carbohydrates,
all these different things that there's
some sort of a,
there's an adverse effect.
Is that,
is that a fact?
If you take a thousand milligrams of
vitamin c will absorb a lot of,
take 10,000
milligrams by percentage,
you won't absorb as much,
but you'll still get more than a
thousand milligrams.
But there's also this theory that sensor
eating basically and no added glucose
diet that there's some kind of
competition in us between glucose and
see.
So even if they get a touch a c,
they're absorbing it hyper efficiently.
Nobody knows.
They haven't developed getting clothes
from glucogenesis uh,
internally,
right?
Because they're adding.
Surely it's a low carb diet and elidel
alpha gal in there.
Maybe that's about the only I think.
I mean,
the point is we just don't know.
We don't know.
And,
and I mean as a,
as a practitioner myself,
and as someone who's dealt with chronic
illness who wasn't able to find help
anywhere else,
I mean,
I,
I do not be grudged people for sticking
with something that they've tried
everything and nothing has worked and
they do this and they feel good.
I mean,
who can blame Them?
It's a dinner with Jordan,
Jordan Peterson.
He's eating these big giant stakes and
he looks great.
He's lighter than he's been since he was
20 and I'm,
I'm 100 percent empathetic with that
because I've been through something like
that myself.
But to then take that and say that we're
certain that it's safe is a big leap.
And so,
you know,
my field atherosclerosis takes years to
develop and I wish him well.
He contributing amazing things in the
world,
but unless he's tracking carotid and
coronary and doing it year after year
after year,
you know,
it's an experiment.
You might not Want to run,
run those tests.
Baseline baseline some nutrient
deficiencies also take many years to
consider.
There's another guy that I follow
online.
I'm sorry,
I forget the gentleman's name,
but he advocates organ meat and he's
saying that organ meat,
if you just eating steak that you've got
an issue,
but if you take into count liver
and heart kidneys that you are going to
get all these essential nutrients from
that you're still not getting vitamin c
that I'm aware of an insignificant
amount.
You're not getting cArotinoids and
flavonoids and people not getting
smaller phenol.
We don't know.
yeah,
so yeah,
we don't know.
Is a good summation of of is it possible
that there's some mechanism that's going
on that picture he was eating steak and
cheese,
so it's apparently not an all meat diet
and I'm not slamming them.
I really wish him well and he can do
what he wants.
I don't know.
Very nice guy.
Yeah.
just detail is important though because
the organ meats and then like fattier
cuts of meat,
have glycine and other nutrients that
are really important.
If you're only eating lean meat,
I think yeah,
I would be very concerned about that.
Children do not try this at home.
Someone tried to get me there were
saying you should try a carnivore diet
for 90 days,
and I said,
well,
the real problem with that be I game and
that's extremely smart and I like
vegetables.
I love vegetables.
I like to eat them.
I eat vegetables with essentially every
single meal.
That's very smart because I told you
it's an antidote if nothing else.
I mean it's.
I do think that it's entirely possible
that maybe it's people that have this
disrupted gut microbiome,
but that some people might be alert.
One of the things that mckayla peterson
brought up when she was on the podcast
that it might very well be that she's
allergic to almost everything.
She has some sort of an allergic
reaction.
You,
I think you both think that that could
be because of a fucked up.
Got my maps.
It's absolutely.
She just hasn't had evaluated.
She,
she started to laugh when I talked to my
naturopath.
That's what you should have kept on
doing.
Gotten her gut analyte and gotten her
gut healed.
I mean maybe that would've helped her,
you know,
kind of problem with those natural path.
It's like good psychics and can I try to
find one?
I'll tell you that it's also not.
Look,
not all problems are solvable,
right?
That's we,
that's a really hard thing to accept.
But let's say you get in a car accident
and your spine is crushed,
you know,
most in short of a miracle,
that's not,
that person's not going to read fully
regained their 100 percent of their
musculoskeletal capabilities.
Right?
But we don't have that same
understanding with other conditions,
health conditions.
Let's say I go to Indonesia and I get 10
parasites and you know,
and,
and then I'd have to take tons of
antibiotics to deal with that.
Is my gut ever going to return to 100
percent of the function that it,
that it had before that even with all
the right things,
maybe not.
And so I'm not saying that the people
should give up hope and I'm saying that
like we have to separate between this is
helping me and it's making me feel great
and nothing else worked.
and we know with 100 percent certainty
that this is safe for the long term.
Those are two very questions
and again,
I'm totally empathetic to that and I
would probably do the same thing,
situate yourself that has gone through
this process of being extremely
unhealthy and I might even say,
hey,
you know,
if I,
maybe I'll die five years earlier,
but I'll enjoy the,
you know,
those years of my life,
I won't be in pain and discomfort the
entire time then sign me up or I might,
I might say to myself,
well wait,
it can't be that good for me to be
inflamed all the time and like,
you know,
that can't be good for me,
so maybe even though the,
the all meat diet might have some
downsides and it actually might be
reducing inflammation and therefore that
will cancel out.
We just don't know.
What about all meat diet?
The thing that gets me is there's no
vitamin supplementation.
I'm like,
what about an all meat diet with good
supplementation of multivitamin and
pretty smart idea.
It was fiber omega three coming fine.
It's being questioned.
I mean it is.
It as centraL to health in the medical
literature,
Dr.
Dennis burkitt from england went to
africa.
Describe fiber described it,
reduced all kinds of chronic diseases
that you wrote,
a book called the fiber man and all.
It's being questioned now.
It's so entrenched.
Have we got it all wrong and only plants
of fiber.
It's a good question.
Where are they getting their fiber?
Their meat is sticking in their colon.
It's called putrefaction for days and
days.
That's is it?
Yeah.
Well it's.
That is what happens and they.
Jaime died at 100 percent with every
single person.
When you chew it well and drink water,
does it always get stuck?
It's generally thought that it's fiber.
That is the process of moving abdominal
contents,
whether you eat a,
a,
an all plant diet or.
No,
I mean I think there's still,
there's definitely controversy about
fiber,
but I think the weight of the evidence
still still does suggested fermentable
carbohydrates.
Fiber essentially beneficial because the
very important for the microbiome and we
have,
you know,
people like justin sonnenburg at
stanford who's done a lot of good work
here.
Um,
do we know with a hundred perCent
certainty?
No,
but we also know that virtually every
human population that's ever been
studied had significant amounts of fiber
in their diet,
so,
so if we're going with die,
right?
No,
they,
they did a very high note,
the warriors,
they consumed the warriors consumed milk
and meat and blood at certain times of
year when they were,
you know,
and,
and other times of year they did eat
more plant foods,
so the white,
the white plants,
but in the,
even the nun,
the traditional knew it,
you know,
they had a d during certain times a
year,
like the winter when the ground was
covered with snow.
They had a very low intake of plant
foods,
but they would still trade for them and
then during the summer when,
when they were able to collect berries
and things like that,
they would definitely do that.
So every culture that we know of that's
been studied,
eight,
some combination of animal and plant
foods,
you know,
what ratio,
what amount,
you know,
that varies place to place
depending on where they are.
Um,
but that's,
that's what the anthropological data
show.
There's actually,
you know,
when you talk about this too,
super,
super cool piece of data.
I'll go quick,
there's a professor at university of
pittsburgh,
steven o'keefe,
who took 20 african americans in
pittsburgh eating and intercity not
healthy diet and 20 rural africans in
South Africa eating from the bush and
largely plants and they switched them
for 20 days and they measured every
single thing they can measure in the
microbiome,
in their stool,
metabolites,
tmao and all the rest.
Your body is so amazing that 20 days on
a better diet,
well,
what I would call the rural african died
a better diet.
You know,
there was incredible changes towards
health,
making butyric acid,
having bacteroidetes and prepatella I
mean changes and the the rural african
suffered american illness in terms of
what you can measure within two weeks
now there's data I just learned
yesterday in los angeles that I'm
microbiome changes in five days.
You go to a low sugar,
low protein plant diet.
This is university of southern
California.
I can tell you in five days michela
peterson's microbiome would change.
Would she feel better?
I don't know.
I'm just pointing out just the
remarkable resiliency and that's part of
the issue.
You can feed a human a whole lot of
diets and make it through procreation,
which is our main purpose of
evolutionary biology to be here.
We're talking about from procreation to
death for optimal health,
longevity,
health span.
there's more than one path.
um,
but let's not beat on our plant base,
the people out there because we've shown
you can reverse atherosclerosis.
We've shown you can reverse prostate
cancer,
university of California south as a use
csf and we've shown you can lengthen
your telomeres,
which may have implications for
longevity.
So it's done through ketogenic diet as
well.
Doesn't that lengthen your telomeres?
I don't think that's been published.
It's a be an interesting project.
You know,
it takes about three to six months,
so you'd have nobody.
No,
it's not been looked at.
And they say the same thing about a diet
that is rich in a,
you know,
vegetables and fruits and animal foods.
You know,
the,
the benefits that you can reverse heart
disease with what you just said.
Don't touch that.
You cannot reverse atherosclerosis with
animal products.
It's never been studied.
The only thing.
so then how can you say you cannot do
it?
Why do we have studies?
What would you tell a patient with the
99 percent blockages that come to me?
Go eat meat.
That's.
We have studies that show that switching
from a standard american diet to a
neutral for diet.
Yeah.
Um,
this is a new word,
neutraL for you coined this sarah
ballantine.
And this is the idea is just plant based
meat.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
it's a whole foods diet with fruits,
vegetables,
nuts and seeds.
Some starchy plants and animal foods.
Why don't you call that paleo?
Now?
The problem with paleo,
paleolithic people didn't really eat
like that.
They had a lot of grains.
So when
I don't think that's for me,
for me,
neutral four is a more inclusive term.
That just means that what I said,
it doesn't necessarily some,
some neutral voice might include some
dairy products.
They might include some grains or
lagoons,
um,
but what they're eating whole real foods
and they're including animal foods there
to distinguish that from vegan or
vegetarian isn't the criticism of the
paleolithic diet or calling it the
paleolithic diet.
The people in the paleolithic era
actually did experience at least some
form of agriculture people.
There has been recent data that suggests
that a green consumption in lagoon
consumption went back further than it
was originally thought it was.
Now,
whether those were prominent parts of
the diet or fall back foods is another
question.
And does that even matter?
I mean,
this is why I've argued that the
evolutionary perspective is important.
it's just a way of generating
hypotheses,
kind of like observational research.
It's not an.
you can't look at what our ancestors ate
and say that therefore that's what we
should eat right now.
You can look at it and say,
oh,
that's interesting.
Let's test this out.
Joel,
how does it reverse
disease?
Okay.
Ketogenic diet and tila mirrors.
There's no sane studies out there.
Just to follow up to know,
um,
how does it reverse heart disease?
You go back to los angeles,
California in 1948,
Dr.
Lester morrison,
internist.
It's real answer.
Saw that in the country of Norway in
world war two where they dropped their
animal food consumption because of the
nazis.
Heart disease slowed for those two,
three years.
He said,
I wonder what happens with my heart
patients in los angeles,
he had 100 of them.
There was no treatment.
in 1948,
he put half of them on a low animal diet
with very high plants that half of them
make like los angeles people.
Eight years later,
50 percent on the high plant lowfat
diet.
We're alive.
Zero percent on the standard.
Los angeles died and then a series of
people said,
let's start doing that more routinely.
Ultimately there were randomized
clinical studies using cath lab
techniques using ultrasound techniques
using pet scanning.
This shows it actually causes small
decreases in the amount of plaque in
your heart arteries,
which results in tripling of blood flow
because it's it's fluid physiology that
is four r squared,
so small decreases in plaque.
Nobody ever thought you could decrease
plaque with diet and lifestyle,
but you can cause this big increase in
flow.
So within three,
four weeks,
chest pain goes away.
Within three,
four months,
stressed us,
get better,
and as you keep going,
a number of hospitalizations procedures
go down dramatically to the point.
Initially small studies got big enough.
In 2010 medicare said,
we'll pay for patients to learn how to
do this reversal lifestyle.
They don't pay for mediterranean diet,
they don't pay for dash diet,
they don't pay for paleo,
keto,
neutral for.
They pay for plant based diets for
advantage
only because the these concepts of
neutral bar and paleo have not been
around for very long.
So all you said
the study,
okay,
you don't
have the millions of dollars to do this
study but don't.
Don't be rigorous.
So all all that you have said,
which I agree with,
is that a plant,
a vegan or plant based kind of diet
compared to a standard american diet
will reverse some markers of
atherosclerosis.
Tip number one,
the.
I agree with that statement,
but there's no.
We don't have research.
It's not like studies have been done
taking people from standard american to
neutral for paleo and we haven't seen
benefits.
We have rcts that have shown significant
benefits in cardiovascular markers,
markers neutral for diets and paleo and
low carb for that matter,
and key to genic.
Your assumption is that the real issues
of standard american diet is killing
people and lack of that lack of evidence
is not evidence against it,
so we don't.
We don't know that.
How long have.
How long have these concepts been around
neutral for paleo?
How many studies have been done looking,
comparing,
for example,
let's do it would be great if we had a
study where you had standard american
diet,
then you had two different groups you
had or a control group of standard
american diet and then you had you know,
vegan diet and then you had neutral for
paleo.
We don't have that study,
so we can't say that that eating a diet
that's rich in whole foods but contained
some animal foods isn't going to reverse
atherosclerosis.
We can't say that.
So I think one thing that we can
absolutely agree on is that the standard
american diet socks and that a vegan
diet is superior to the standard
american diet.
These,
these two men,
these two things are if the vegan
implementing wisely,
wisely.
I just tell you,
and this is very subtle,
but vegan diets as which you can't do.
You can't eat dairy and eggs,
you can't eat fish can eat whole food.
Plant based is really the proper medical
term.
What do you eat?
Eat john.
Joseph talks about too,
he calls it call with a whole food plant
based because you,
you know,
you don't want to be just eating pasta
all day.
Oh absolutely.
No food vegetarian or junk food vegan
diet.
So the dispute is whether or not animal
protein in organ meats will advance your
health and,
and,
and make in debt.
It's a superior diet when you add that
one quarter of your plate.
So yeah,
I'm.
One of the ways to answer this is to
look at nutrient density.
So I have this study on my websites,
my yo,
I think my low and my french is
terrible.
M a I l l o,
t and m,
uh,
it's uh,
[inaudible] dot com slash rogan,
um,
and he looked at nutrient density of
foods and categorize them based on
nutrient density and he was only looking
at,
he was looking at essential nutrients,
so all the vitamins and minerals that we
absolutely need for health.
He wasn't looking at polyphenols and
flavonoids and things like that,
which are beneficial,
but we don't absolutely need.
So the number one food in terms of
nutrient density,
do you want to guess what organ meats
organized score of seven.
Fifty four.
Next highest shellfish.
Six 43.
And I've often said this to my patients
like kale,
you can be a vegetarian or an only eat
organ,
meats and shellfish,
you'd be doing really well because of
just how nutrient dense they are.
And that's not really a controversial.
Let me come here.
Fatty fish,
six slash 22.
Lean fish is three 75.
Um,
and then vegetables or 3:52
so that,
you know,
vegetables are on there,
but a organ,
meat,
shellfish,
fatty fish,
lean fish,
um,
are all higher than,
than vegetables and grains and lagoons
don't even really make the,
you know,
they're nowhere close in terms of
nutrient density.
I think we can all agree that,
uh,
when someone goes from the standard
american diet to a vegan diet,
there's a real reason why they're
experiencing significant health
benefits,
particularly if they supplement.
YeAh,
yeah,
that's right.
That's true.
Are highly processed and refined,
assuming they're eating a whole foods
vegan diet and not just subsisting on
begets and cookies and stuff like that,
which unfortunately people do.
We'll do just like people eat the
standard american diet and you know,
for that matter,
just like people who go paleo and,
and,
and are eating paleo donuts and paleo
ice cream,
whatever,
you know,
like you can do it on any dietary
approach.
No foods.
It was going to say,
you know,
I never have proposed except for one
small subset that everybody needs to eat
a completely plant based diet.
But if they do,
they're probably going to have good
health.
There's a concept called the spectrum.
Dr.
Dean ornish,
some people beat up on,
but he's done all these studies on
reversal of atherosclerosis and he
celebrated around the world.
Has a book called the spectrum.
Go as far towards it as you can.
I'll love you wherever you're at,
you choose.
We're not judging you.
And that's I think the message for your
listeners.
I mean it what you're eating vegetables
or fruit or maybe it's just vegetables.
Every meal.
That's the example people need to hear
and they don't need to abandon
everything else.
Just don't do it with a donut.
Don't do it with a bagel.
Don't do these calorie empty.
And also time restricted eating.
I think we all agree on the awesome.
Twelve hours,
14 hours a day.
I'm a big fan of four or five days a
month,
lowering calories with low protein,
low sugar,
and now the science is coming out.
Unbelievable.
It's right here from los angeles.
No,
I mean,
so I want to say that we're talking
about helping people and I was a vegan
at one point and a vegetarian and I have
friends that are vegans and vegetarians.
Again,
I'm not ideological about this at all.
And um,
so I want to say like,
so someone who is a vegetarian or vegan
and just to show how nutrient dense
organ meats and shellfish are,
if you want it to be a vegan but you're
not,
you know,
ideologically opposed to eating some
small amount of animal product or animal
food,
you could eat one clam oyster and four
grams,
which is a tiny amount of liver a day
and you would completely meet your needs
for b12,
zinc,
copper,
coleen,
and many other nutrients with no other
consumption of animal foods beyond that.
So this is what I said before,
like the spectrum is large,
you know,
some people might consume a much,
a higher percentage of animal foods.
Some people could consume just that much
and they would still improve their
health and wellbeing by doing that from
then eating a strictly a plant diet.
And,
uh,
one thing that I do have to tell you,
joel,
unfortunately,
is that you keep saying that nick and
nate diaz or vegan,
I know they,
they've fallen back.
I don't keep saying it,
but they've fallen back.
Well,
you brought it up a bunch of times,
but he was.
When he,
when he won the fight,
he was,
he was eating fish,
fish and eggs.
That's cool.
I worry about this tape,
male level,
but it's cool.
No,
I'm serious.
But you know,
the explosion,
the Tennessee titans and kyrie irving
and serena williams.
I mean serena williams is vegan as well.
Yeah.
She reversed and auto immune disease
called sjogren's.
Yeah.
So is it isn't necessary to be plant
based to be a world class athlete?
Obviously not.
Is it compatible to be.
Do you know who patrick bamyan holds a
world record for power lifting?
He's been plant based his whole life.
Big,
stocky litho guy up.
Patrick,
pat,
r I k,
I mean it's this big stocky german,
but he lives 1200 pounds and he has the
world record.
He hasn't eaten some meat.
None.
Nick delgado a nema delgado.
Nick,
the point is it's an option to be a
super athlete without animal products.
We're seeing it more and more recovery.
Which troll on your thing,
but you know it happens.
Just stop beating on us because we're
doing pretty well,
but yeah,
fds has gone back to eating fish and
vegetables.
It's a whole lot better than the crap
american diet that a lot of athletes
say.
They just cut out all the land animals.
Yeah.
You initially started doing it to make.
Wait,
okay.
Yeah,
I got it.
Got it,
got it.
A lot of people are talking about
quicker recovery that.
I mean there's some like alex and sarah
sees the world
class fighter.
He's.
He's completely vegan.
Sean o'malley was for awhile,
but he found himself to have much more
energy when he started eating meat,
but he might've been.
He might've been doing it wrong or not.
My biome and supplementation.
Yeah,
believe it,
you know,
but that's really cool.
This,
I forget her name right now,
the chef that cooked for 15 Tennessee
titans and you know,
they're just kicking ass and griff
wailin used to be with the miami
dolphins.
I forget where he is now,
oakland raiders,
you know,
a great,
great tight end and such.
I mean,
it's possible that we can say scott
jurek set the world record for the
appalachian trail faster than either the
person eat beans.
I mean,
insane.
A level of athletic fitness.
The appalachian trail.
yeah.
It's like 24,
100,
2,400
miles fast as human to ever accomplish
it on beans.
I mean,
pretty cool.
this was such an amazing thing to watch
a documentary.
Yeah.
Should we wrap this up?
Wow.
We obviously we've left
flat on the table.
It was still alive.
We did,
that's disputed.
But uh,
I think one thing that we came to a
really solid conclusion,
not as a standard american diet sucks
and any deviation from it,
that's a whole food based diet and
especially with proper nutrients that
are supplemented if you're vegan or what
have you,
is going to be better than standard
american diet.
The dispute is whether or not the
nutrient dense organ meats,
shellfish,
meat,
fish,
and these things would eggs.
That these would benefit you
significantly.
And I think that's how we got through
it,
like very peacefully,
just just
eat real food,
real food.
I actually refer people in san francisco
to chris.
I honor what he's doing.
I mean we may have this dispute about
saturated fat and cholesterol and it's
not unimportant,
but he is a prime practitioner.
He's treating people at the right level.
I believe I'm doing that in detroit.
And the people that come to see me,
you know,
where the solution.
We're not the problem despite the
differences.
And you're a good man to bring us on,
you know,
point all that out.
both handled yourself admirably.
I mean this is,
this is a very emotional,
tightly contested sort of a dispute.
And I,
I thank you both very much for being
here.
Well thanks for the opportunity to joe.
I mean the have the chance to do this
for what almost four hours now.
That's amazing.
And it serves people because on most tv
segments it's like five minutes and you
just get the headlines and there's no
depth.
So you get these click bait articles and
it's confusing.
So thanks for giving us the chance to
really dive deeply on it.
Anybody that wants more,
download chris's references.
Go to my website,
the rogan references,
you know,
read more study time.
Um,
yeah,
dr joel kahn.com.
Big red button rogan references.
You can keep yourself busy for tWitter,
which is on my page.
But as had dr j k a h n dr j dot scott
and chris.
Uh,
chris kresser.com/rogan
for all the research here.
E s s e r slash rogen and tHen chris
kresser twitter.
all right,
beautiful.
Thank yOu guys.
It was really fun.
Thank you.
Mm hmm.